İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 30 Eylül 2024 Pazartesi günü, Eylül ayının son günü.
27. ders günümüz. Saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz.
Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Geçen dersimizin konusu RTTI'di. Runtime Type Identification ya da Runtime Type Information.
Type ID operatöründe kalmıştık. Bunu şimdilik bitirmek üzereydik.
Bu konu bittikten sonra yine kursun en önemli konularından birinin başlayacağını söylemiştim.
Exception Handling konusu.
Şöyle bir hatırlayalım. Geçen dersin son 5 dakikasına gidelim.
Ama önce nerede kaldık? Bir hatırlayalım.
Konumuz programın çalışma zamanında tür belirlenmesi.
Daha çok tabi burada kast edilen dinamik türün belirlenmesi.
Davranışa esas olan türün.
İki tane operatörün varlığından bahsettik.
Önce Dynamic Cast operatörünü gördük.
Sonra da Type ID operatörünü görmeye başladık.
Şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Bir kere Type ID operatörünün Dynamic Cast operatöründen birinci farkı
sadece polimorfik türler için kullanılmakla sınırlı olmayışı.
Polimorfik olsun ya da olmasın Type ID operatörünü kullanabiliyoruz.
Type ID operatörüyle oluşturulan bir ifade bir Type Info nesnesine karşılık geliyordu.
İşte bu Type Info sınıfı C++'ın standart kütüphanesinin Type Info başlık dosyasında değil mi?
Include Type Info.
Bazı başlık dosyaları Type Info'yu kendisi de dahil ediyor olabilir.
Ama Type ID operatörünü kullanmak için Type Info başlık dosyasını include etmekte her zaman fayda var.
Type ID operatörüyle oluşturulan bir ifade.
Çok hızlı bir tekrar yapalım.
Bir şekilde kullanılabiliyordu.
Size of operatöründe olduğu gibi
ya bir tür bilgisi ya da bir expression.
Type ID operatörü bizi operant olan türle
ya da operant olan ifadenin türüne ilişkin bir Type Info nesnesine eriştiriyordu.
Bu Type Info nesnesi const bir nesne.
Yani bize bir const Type Info reference veriyordu.
Yani bu ne demek?
Örneğin auto ampersan r eşittir Type ID x gibi bir ifade oluşturursam
auto type deduction kurallarına göre
auto yerine gelen tür
const Type Info olacak
ve bunun da r referansı
const Type Info LValue referansı olacak.
const bir nesneye referans olduğu için
şöyle yazamayacağımızı hatırlayın arkadaşlar.
Type Info const olmayan bir LValue referans kullanamam.
Yazacaksın ya şöyle yazmalıyım
const Type Info ref.
Bu arada şunu da söyleyelim.
Sadece Type Info sınıfının ne olduğunu anlatmak için
ve Type ID operatörünün aslında bizi neye eriştirdiğini göstermek için
bunu yazıyorum.
Yoksa bir C++ kodunda
lakin nadiren
Type ID operatörünün oluşturulduğu ifadeyi
bir referans değişkene bağlamam
nadiren söz konusu olabilir.
Type ID operatörünün bizi eriştirdiği
Type Info nesnesinin
ilişkin olduğu sınıfın
şöyle bir özelliği vardı.
Aslında en son söylediğimiz cümle şuydu.
Bir Type Info nesnesini kullanmanın tek yolu
Type ID operatörü.
Eğer ben Type Info nesnesini
default construct etmek istersem
yani şöyle bir kod yazsaydım
stut
Type Info tx
default constructörü olmadığı için
syntax hatası olacaktı
ve var olan bir Type Info nesnesinin
kopyasını çıkartmak istersem
örneğin Type ID x
arkadaşlar
Type Info y
bu sefer de
Copy Constructörü ve
Copy Memberları
delete edildiği için
bu yine mümkün olmuyordu.
Type Info sınıfının
arkadaşlar
bizi ilgilendiren
birkaç tane önemli
üye fonksiyonu var.
Zaten çok küçük bir interfejse sahip
fakat bizi ilgilendiren en önemli fonksiyon
eşit eşit
karşılaştırma operatör fonksiyonu
ya da eşit değil.
Bu fonksiyonu kullanarak
bir Type Info nesnesini
başka bir Type Info nesnesiyle
eşitlik karşılaştırmasına sokabilirim.
Eğer eşitlik
true sonuçlanırsa
bunlar aynı türe ilişkin
Type Info nesnelere
posta sonuçlanırsa
farklı türlere ilişkin.
Ve eğer
Type ID operatörü
polimorfik bir
sınıf türüyle ilgili
kullanılmıyorsa
her zaman
statik türe ilişkin bize
bilgi veriyor.
Onu da geçen dersimizde
göstermiştik.
Class
My Class
Örneğin My Class
polimorfik bir sınıf değil
ya da Class Base
Class
der
Public Base
Her bir kalıtım var
ama
Runtime Polimorfizmi yok.
Onlara şöyle bir şey yazsaydım
örneğin
der
Myder
Base
Yıldız
Base PTR
Eşittir Myder
Adres Myder
Hype ID
Yıldız Base PTR
Yeşit Eşit
Hype ID
Arkadaşlar
Der
Bu eşitlik
OZ olarak sonuçlanacak.
Çünkü burada
statik tür
esas olacak.
Hatta bunu
bir de gösterelim.
Iostream
Bahşet dosyasını dahil edelim.
Tam da bu arada
derste kaldığımız yer
burasıydı.
Efendim
Bu
Life
Tut
See Out
Burada yine
ADL'den faydalandığımızı da bir hatırlatalım.
Operatör önceliği yüzünden
ifademizi
öncelik parantezi içine alalım.
Ve
True
ya da
False
olarak
eşitliğin sonucunu
standart
altta
yazdıralım
Allah'ın ismiyle.
Evet
False
Ama şimdi bakın
sınıfı
polimorfik yapayım.
Public
herhangi bir virtual function
eklemem yeterli biliyorsunuz
sınıfı
polimorfik yapmak için.
Ben de
virtual
destraktör
ettim.
Virtual
field
base
eşittir
default
kendim de
tanımlayabilirdim.
Artık
Type ID
operatörü
bana
dinamik türe
ilişkin bilgi
verecek.
Yani şu anda
eğer başka bir yerde
bir hata
yapmadıysak
standart
output'a
True
yazmalı.
Oraya kadar
anlamadığımız bir şey
var mı?
Tekrar etmek gerekirse
Type ID
operatörü
polimorfik
olmayan türler için
statik türe
ilişkin bilgi veriyor.
Polimorfik türler
söz konusu olduğunda
dinamik türe
ilişkin bilgi veriyor.
Bu arada
şunu da göstermiş
olduk.
Bir nesnenin
dinamik türünün
ne olduğunu
sorgulamak için
örneğin
polimorfik bir
sınıfı
gösterecek
sınıf nesnesini
pointer'ı
d-referans ettiğimiz
ifadeyi
Type ID
operatörün
operanda yapıp
dinamik türü
sınıfın
eşit eşit
operatör
fonksiyonuyla
sınayabiliriz.
Birazdan
örnek vereceğim.
Arkadaşlar
sınıfın
diğer
fonksiyonlarına
gelince
sınıfın
name isimli
fonksiyonu
Type ID
efendim
yıldız
base
ptr
nokta
name
gördüğünüz gibi
const
gestring
döndürüyor
const char
yıldız
döndürüyor
o türe ilişkin
tamamen
derleyiciye
bağlı
bir yazı
döndürüyor.
Buraya dikkat.
Bu yazı
derleyiciden
derleyiciye
fark edebilir.
Mesela
bu
Microsoft
derleyicisinde
tür
gerçekten
çok açık
bir şekilde
yazıyla
betimleniyor.
So
see out
muhtemelen
ekranda
göreceğimiz
yazı
class
der
olacak.
Fakat örneğin
C lang
ya da
GCC
derleyicilerinde
kriptik
bir yazı
veriyor.
Yani
bir şekilde
kendisine
göre
ne yapmış?
bir
notasyon
uygulamış.
A, B, C,
X, Y, Z
gibi bir
yazı çıkarsa
şaşırmayın
diye söylüyorum.
Ama sonuçta
şöyle bir garanti
var.
Aynı türe
ilişkin
name
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
aynı derleyici de
aynı yazıyı
döndürecek.
Yazının
aynı olması
bir yerde
garanti altında.
arkadaşlar
henüz
konteyner
sınıfları
görmeye
başlamadık.
Tahmin
edebileceğiniz
gibi
birçok
arkadaşım
başka
programlama
dillerinden
konteyner
ya da
onlarda
karşılık
karşılığıyla
collectionlara
alışık.
Sınıfın
Type ID
Yıldız
Base
PDR
dikkat ederseniz
arkadaşlar
hash code
diye bir
fonksiyonu
var.
Doğrudan
bize
hashing
amaçlı
kullanılacak
size
D türünden
bir
değer döndürüyor.
Aslında bu
şu demek
biz
Type
info
nesneleri
Type
info
bir sınıf
değil mi?
Type
info
sınıfı
türünden
nesneler
olabilir
değil mi?
Type
info
nesnelerini
başka
sınıf
nesnelerini
tuttuğumuz
gibi bir
konteyner
da tutabiliriz.
Bu
konteyner
işte
unordered
set
map
gibi
bir
konteyner
da
olabilir.
Orada
hashing
amaçlı
sınıfın
fonksiyonları
kullanılabilir.
Yani
aslında
bu
pratikte
ne
demek?
Benim
bunu
bir
unordered
map
ya da
unordered
maldi
map
gibi
bir
konteyner
da
tutma
şansım
var.
Doğrudan
hash
yapabiliyorum
anlamına
geliyor
arkadaşlar.
Yani bir
hash table
da
veri yapısı
ismiyle
tutmamda
bir engel
yok.
O zaman
şöyle bir
toparlarsak
eşit eşit
eşit
değil
name
hash
kod
gibi
fonksiyonları
var.
Ama bizim
üretimde
kullanacağımız
tipik olarak
eşit eşit
ve eşit
değil
fonksiyonları
bazen de
name
fonksiyonu
ama o
az önce
söylediğim gibi
derleyiciye
bağlı.
Arkadaşlar
type
id
operatörünün
bir önemli
özelliği
daha var.
Unevaluated
kontekst
oluşturuyor.
Unevaluated
kontekstin
ne olduğunu
daha önce
konuşmuştuk.
C'de
sadece
size
of
operatörü
için
geçerli.
Tabii
variable
length
array'den
bahsetmiyorum.
Fakat
C++'da
birçok
yerde
unevaluated
kontekst
söz konusu
örneğin
decal
type
size
of
operatörü
gibi
daha başka
yerlerle de
karşılaşacağız.
Type
id
operatörü
de
arkadaşlar
unevaluated
kontekst
yani bu ne
demek?
Örneğin
intür'den bir
değişkenim
olsun
ve ben
to see out
type
id
x
artı
name
şöyle bir
kod
yazayım
x
değişkeni
değeri
değişecek
mi?
Fatih
Sevencan
Alihan
Bozkır
İbrahim
Özer
hayır
zaten
unevaluated
kontekst
bu demek
değil mi?
işlem kodu
üretilmeyen
bağlam
evet
devam edelim
Oğuz'dan
sorunuza
cevap vereceğim
evet
aynı şekilde
stu type
index'i de
kullanabilirsiniz
ona da
örnek veririm
evet
şimdi
x
ilişkeninin
değerini
yazdıralım
arkadaşlar
x
değişkenin
değerinin
5 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
tabii
şimdi
burada
genellikle
kitaplarda
yazmayan
bence
önemli olan
bir nokta
var
unevaluated
kontekstle
ilgili
daha önce de
söylemiştim
normalde
bir ifade
arkadaşlar
yürütüldüğünde
tanımsız
davranış olabilir
değil mi?
örneğin
sıfıra bölme
now pointer'ı
dereferans etme
örneğin
bir dizinin
olmayan
indeksli
elemanına
erişme
unevaluated
kontekste
kullanırsanız
sentax açısından
legalse
bir tanımsız
davranış
söz konusu
değil
örneğin
on elemanlı
bir dizi
olsun
ve ben
type ID
operatöründe
operandı
A köşeli
parantez
yapayım
burada
normalde
dizinin
olmayan
indisi
ve elemanına
eriştiğim için
ne olması
gerekir?
Arkadaşlar
bir
tanımsız
davranış
olması
gerekir
ama
bu ifade
yürütülmediği
için
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir tanımsız
davranış
ne olmayacak?
Söz
konusu
olmayacak
şimdi
buradaki
koda bakalım
bu
biraz
cpp
reference
dot com
dan alıp
biraz
değiştirdiğim
bir
kod
şimdi
diyor ki
bu önemli
type ID
aynı türe
ilişkin
type info
nesnesine
gördüğünüz gibi
iki tane
referans
alınmış
arkadaşlar
buradaki
nesnelerin
adresleri
aynı
olmak
zorunda
değil
yani
derleyici
şöyle bir
kod üretmek
zorunda
değil
ortada
tek bir
nesne
var
nerede
kullanırsanız
kullanın
aslında
aynı
nesneyi
kullanıyorsunuz
dolayısıyla
bakın
açık açık
ne yazmış
may fail
yani
bu
assertion
doğrulanmayabilir
ama
aynı türe
ilişkinse
eşit
operatör
fonksiyonu
true
değer vermek
zorunda
yani
bu
assertion
her zaman
tutacak
ingilizce
hold
edecek
hash
kod için
yine aynı
yani
aynı
türe
ilişkin
type info
nesneleriyse
hash
kodları
aynı
olmak
zorunda
yine
henüz
biz görmedik
ama
ileride
göreceğiz
yine
standart
kütüphanenin
type
index
isimli bir
fonksiyonu
var
type
index
demin
Oğuzhan Bey'in
bahsettiği
fonksiyon
type
index
evet
görüyorsunuz
type info
nesnesi
istiyor
ve
şöyle
gösterelim
type
index
bir fonksiyon
değil
bu arada
bir sınıf
type
index
yine
type
index
değerlerinin
eşit
olması
garanti
altında
ve
yine
name
fonksiyonunun
döndürdüğü
yazılar
karşılaştırıldığında
bu yazılar
bu yazı adresleri
eşit
olmak
zorunda
diyor
standart
bundan sonraki
konumuz
exception
handling
ya
hadi
oraya da
bir gönderme
yapalım
arkadaşlar
standart
kütüphanenin
gönderdiği
exception'lardan
biri
ilginç
pipe
id
operatörünün
kullanımına
ilişkin
eğer dinamik
bir türümüz
varsa
tekrar şu
class
base'e
geri dönelim
evet
ama
buraya dikkat
dinamik
bir tür
söz konusu
ip
id
operatörünü
kullanırken
ip
id
operatörüne
operant olarak
verdiğimiz
ifade
eğer
null pointer'ı
dereferans etme
ifadesi ise
örneğin
base
yield
ptr
değeri
null pointer
olsun
arkadaşlar
biliyorsunuz
value initialize
ettiğimde
null pointer
olma garantisi
var
onu da
vurgulamış
olalım
şimdi
pipe
id
yield
base
ptr
hatta
şöyle yapalım
name fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
sözde
ve standart
output'a
yazıyı
yazdıralım
ve bakın
ne olduğuna
bakalım
önce böyle
bir
debug edelim
arkadaşlar
bu
henüz
görmedik
ama
birazdan
epey
düşeceğiz
bir
exception
gönderildiği
ve exception
yakalanamadığı
anlamına
ineriyor
ingilizce'de
uncaught
exception
deniyor
şimdi bu
exception'ı
yakalamaya
çalışayım
burada
detaylı
konuyu
anlamamız
gerekmiyor
sadece
programın
akışı
bu
catch
bloğunun
içine
girerse
bir exception
gönderilmiş
ve bu
exception
yakalanmış
demektir
ben de
bunu
göstereceğim
arkadaşlar
burada gönderilen
exception'in ismi
bad type
id
standart kütüphanenin
exception
hiyerarşisindeki
suit exception
taban sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
bir sınıf
dolayısıyla
bu exception'ı
kendi türüyle de
yani
bad type
id ile de
yakalayabilirdim
exception
god
bunu unutmayalım
now pointer'ı
dereferens etme
ifadesi
polimorfik sınıflar
için
bad type
id
sınıfı
türünden
bir exception
gönderilmesine
neden
oluyor
şimdi
gelelim
kullanımına
arkadaşlar
şimdi de
type id
operatörünün
kullanımıyla
dynamic cast
operatörünün
kullanımı
aslında özünde
aynı amaca
hizmet edebilir
hemen her zaman
her zaman
değil de
çoğunlukla
fakat
kullanım biçimleri
farklı bir
dynamic cast
operatörü
down casting'in
başarılı olarak
garanti altında
yapılıp
yapılamayacağını
sınıyordu
gibi kullanımı
buydu
ama up casting
ve side casting
için de
kullanılabiliyordu
ve özellikle
geçen dersimizde
bir şey hatırlıyor
musunuz
burada
tekrar
şu bizim
örneklerde
kullandığımız
kar sınıfına
bakalım
volvo xc90
public volvo
hatta kodu da
yazalım
eğer sıkılmazsanız
bir tekrar
edilmiş olur
şöyle bir
kod yazmıştık
bir döngü
içinde
kar başlık
dosyasını
dahil edelim
artık açıklama
gereği duymuyorum
son birkaç
terstir
kullanıyoruz
örneklerde
create random
card
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
dynamic cast
operatörüyle
volvo
türüne
cast
ettim
yani
down castingin
run time'da
başarılı olup
olmadığını
sunuyorum
tipik
idiomatik
yapıyı
kullanalım
if
volvo
yıldız
arkadaşlar
vptr
eşittir
dynamic cast
volvo
yıldız
kar ptr
eğer
ifin doğru
kısmına
girerse
bu bir
volvo
demektir
c
out
arkadaşlar
yıldız
vptr
burada
durdurmuştuk
yine aynı şeyi yapalım
void
get car
bu kodu bir hatırlamamızı istiyorum
önemli
run time'a bakalım
evet bakın
volvo xc90
o da bir volvo
yani hem volvo için
hem de volvo xc90 için
dynamic cast
başarılı oluyor
şimdi kodu biraz değiştirelim
ve type id operatörünü
kullanalım
peki type id operatörünü
nasıl kullanacağız
arkadaşlar son derece
basit
if
type id
yıldız
kar ptr
eşit eşit
type id
volvo
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
c out
yıldız
kar ptr
bu arada yıldız
ifadesinin
standart
alt kuda
verilebilmesinin
nedeni
bizim
bunun için
bir fonksiyon
yazmış olmamız
o derste olmayan
arkadaşlar
hani bunu doğrudan
bilim desteği
sanmasınlar
diye söylüyorum
void
get car
önce buraya kadar
giderleyelim
şunu kapatalım
bakıncim sadece
görüyorsunuz değil mi
volvo
yani ben
volvo xc90
olup olmadığında
sınamam gerekiyorsa
onun için
ayrı bir kontrol
yapmalıyım
mesela veya
operatörüyle
bağlamak gibi
burada önemli bir nokta
daha var
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
peki
diyelim ki
burada benim amacım
volvo ise
volvo'nun
sunroofunu
açmak
öyleydi galiba
örneğimiz
değil mi
evet
volvo
gördüğünüz gibi
havan sınıfta
olmayan
polimorfikte olmayan
open sunroof
isimli
bir fonksiyon var
fakat şu anda elimde
halen
rptr var
yani burada
rptr
ok
open sunroof
yazarsam
bu statik olarak
compile time'de
hata verecek
isim arama
name look
hatası olacak
değil mi
dolayısıyla
şimdi ben
volvo
pointer'ına
ihtiyacım var
burada bazen
şöyle komik
kod görüyorum
burada birkaç
kere gördüm
siz de
görürsünüz
tekrar da
aynı bir kest
yapıyor
hayır hayır
burada dynamic kest
yapmayacağız
zaten if'in doğru
kısmına girmesi
runtime'da
onun bir
volvo olduğunun
kanıtı
ne yapacağız
statik kest
yapacağız
volvo
yıldız
vptr
eşittir
statik kest
volvo yıldız
geçen dersimizde
konuşmuştuk
bu
sentax hatası
değil
rptl
artık biz zaten
onun
ne olduğunu
biliyoruz
bir volvo
olduğunu
biliyoruz
değil mi
ve
arkadaşlar
vptl
ok
open
sarıf
bu arada
tabi ki
bu nesneleri
delete etmek de
gerekiyor
konumuz olmadığı için
demin yazmadım ama
destraktörümüzün
virtual olduğunu
hatırlatalım
destraktör virtual
olmasaydı
bu da
tanımsız davranış
olacaktı
rptr
evet
void
getgar
bakın
arkadaşlar bu arada
mülakatlarda şöyle bir soru
sorabiliyorlar
iki tane soru
aslında
birincisi
tahmin etmenizi
istiyorum
nasıl
programın
çalışma
zamanda
dinamik tür
belli oluyor
yani
dynamic cast
operatörü
olsun
type
id
operatörü
olsun
burada
derleyicilerin
ürettiği
kodda
programın
çalışma
zamanında
örneğin
onun
bir volvo
olup
olmadığını
nasıl
anlıyorum
aslında
tahmin etmek
zor
değil
tipik
implementasyon
şöyle
runtime
polimorfizmini
anlatırken
derleyicilerin
virtual
dispatch
için
nasıl bir
kod
ürettiğinden
bahsetmiştik
tipik olarak
bir
virtual
function
table
oluşturuyorlardı
ve
polimorfik
sınıf
nesnesinin
içine
bu
tabloyu
gösterecek
yani
virtual
function
table
gösterecek
o veri yapısını
bir pointer
gömüyorlardı
ve
aslında
polimorfik
çağrıyı da
bir
indekse
dönüştürüp
compile time'da
pointer'ın
gösterdiği
nesnenin
sanal fonksiyon
tablo göstericisine
eriş
bir
indirection
o tablodaki
belirli
indeksteki
fonksiyonu
çağır
bu şekilde
kod ürettiğini
söylemiştik
aslında tipik
implementasyon
şöyle
aynı tablonun
belirli bir
indeksini
diyelim ki
sıfır indeksini
hype info
nesnesi
için kullanıyor
arkadaşlar
type info
nesnesi
için kullanılıyor
dolayısıyla
aslında
biz
gerek
dynamic
cast
operatörüyle
gerek
type
id
operatörüyle
dinamik türün
sorgulamasını
yaptığımızda
aslında
sanal fonksiyon
tablosu
yoluyla
erişilen
bir
type info
nesnesini
kullanıyoruz
bu
kadar basit
bu birinci soru
nasıl
implemente edildi
ikinci soru
ki cevabını
bir yerde
ima etmişte
oldum
hangisinin
maliyeti
daha yüksek
yani
tipik bir örnekte
dinamik
türün
dynamic
cast
operatörüyle
özür dilerim
ya da
type
id
operatörüyle
belirlenmesi
arasında
bir maliyet
farkı varsa
cost
yani
işlem maliyetinden
bahsediyorum
hangisinde
daha yüksek
olmasını
beklersiniz
dynamic
cast
de mi
yoksa
type
id
operatöründe
mi
bu bir soru
o
san
esin
alian
bozkır
dynamic
cast
maliyet
tipik olarak
daha yüksek
neden
aslında son derece
basit
yani maliyet
daha yüksekse
nedeni
işte az önceki örnek
ben
car
pointer
türünden
volvo
pointer
türüne
cast
ettiğimde
onun
bir
volvo
olup olmadığını
anlamak
için
sınıf
hiyerarşisinde
en dibe
kadar
gitmek
zorunda
yani
volvo
mu
xc90
mı
volvo
xc90
dizel
mi
volvo
xc90
dizel
hibrit
mi
uyduruyorum
tabi
böyle
arabalar
yok
bunların
hepsini
sınama
sorunda
ama
typeid
sadece
belirli türe
bakıyor
o yüzden
iki kodun
karşılaştırmasını
da yaptım
burası
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
bu arada
ben
typeid
operatörünü
biraz
amacının
dışında
eğitim
amaçlı
da
jenerik
programlama
tarafında
da kullanacağım
çünkü
bazen
jenerik
programlama
tarafında
arka
planda
ne oluyor
onu göstermek
için
biraz
pratik
yol haline
geliyor
yani
üretimde
kullanmak
amaçlı
değil
neyi
kastediyorum
sadece
bir örnek
vereyim
mesela
bakın
çok yakında
araya
bir iki
konu daha
aldıktan
sonra
artık
kursun
görece
olarak
zor bölümlerinden
biri başlayacak
jenerik
programlama
bölümü
diyelim ki
bu bir
komisyon
şablonu
void
bank
p
derleyici
bu
fonksiyon
şablonundan
sonsuz sayıda
fonksiyon
oluşturabilir
yani
teknik
terimiyle
bu fonksiyon
şablonundan
onlarca
yüzlerce
specialization
oluşturabilir
ama
derleyicinin
ürettiği
kodda
derleyicinin
t türeği
için
ne
kullandığını
görme amaçlı
bazen şöyle
yazacağım
burada
bazı noktalara
dikkat etmek
gerekiyor
sadece
type ID
operatörünü
pratik
size bir şey
anlatırken
kullanacağımı
göstermek
için
bu arada
tabi
benim derleyicimin
kriptik olmayan
bir yazı
sağlaması da
benim işimi
kolaylaştıracak
örneğin
punk'ı
intürden
argümanla
double
türden
argümanla
unsight
intürden
argümanla
ve
charterden
argümanla
çağırdım
şimdi
runtime'a
bakınız
aslında
çağırdığım
dört fonksiyonda
ayrı fonksiyonlar
derleyici
bu fonksiyon
şablonundan
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon
oluşturduğu
ayrı fonksiyonları
olduğunu
göstermenin
yollarından
biridir
işte
görüyorsunuz
type ID
operatörü
ile eriştiğim
type info
nesnelerinin
her birinden
farklı olması
evet
şimdilik
runtime type
identification'la
ilgili
söyleyeyim
bu
yalnız
arada bir şey
de söyleyelim
arkadaşlar
c++ 17
standartıyla
dile eklenen
ve popüler olarak
vocabulary types
denilen
üç tane
sınıf
var
bunlar
stud
optional
variant
ve stud
any
orada
isminden de
anlaşılacağı gibi
stud
any
öyle bir
sınıf
türü ki
o sınıf
türünden
bir nesne
may hold
any
values
herhangi türden
bir değer
tutabilir
orada da
tahmin edersiniz
type info
sınıfının
bir kullanımı
söz konusu
any
sınıfını
incelemeye
geçtiğinizde
STL
konuları
arasında
belki
type info
sınıfına
dolayısıyla
type ID
operatörünü
bir şekilde
type ID
operatörünün
ilişkin olduğu
type info
sınıfına
da
bir
gönderme
yapmış
olacağız
o zaman
Cengiz Han
hocam
Vtable
o nesnenin hangi
türü olduğunu
ve sanal
fonksiyonlarının
adreslerini
mi
içerir
diyoruz
öyle
şimdi
şöyle
biraz
tedbirli
konuşalım
daha önce de
söyledim
C++
standardı
Virtual Dispatch
mekanizmasının da
RTTI'ın da
nasıl
implemente edileceği
konusunda
herhangi bir
ne diyelim
şeyi empoze
etmiyor
edemez
zaten
C++
standardı
her zaman
suite makine
üstünde
yani
implementasyona
karışmaz
benim söylediğim
tipik
implementasyonun
bu
olduğu
yani
Virtual
Table'ın
gerçekten de
hem
herhangi bir sınıf
için oluşturulan
Virtual
Table'ın
hem
sanal
fonksiyonların
adreslerine
yani o sınıfın
override'larından
bahsediyorum
tutması
indekste
ama tipik olarak
aynı tablonun
belirli bir
indeksinin de
neye ayrılması
Type
info
nesnesine
ayrılması
bu arada
Cengizhan
açıklayıcı
olduğumu
bilmiyorum
tipik
implementasyon
böyle
bu arada şunu
da söyleyelim
Cengizhan Bey'in
sorusu
başka bir
şeyi de
getirdi
derleyiciler
tipik olarak
şöyle bir
switch'e
sahip
hatta
bilmiyorum
C++'la
bundan böyle
yaşlar genelde
küçük tahmin
ediyorum ama
10 sene
önce de ben
C++'la
kod yazıyordum
diyen
arkadaşlarım varsa
belki onları
hatırlayacak
mesela Visual
Studio'da
tam senesini
hatırlamıyorum
hangi sürüm
olduğunu
hatırlamıyorum
ama
bu
runtime
type
identification
default
olarak
kapalıydı
yani
siz
RTTI'dan
faydalanmak
istediğiniz
zaman
bir switch'le
onu seçiyordunuz
aktif hale
getiriyordunuz
fakat
daha sonradan
default haline
RTTI
açık bir
şekilde
düzenlediler
siz de
derleyicimize
bakınız
derleyicilerin
hemen hepsinde
olmayanını
görmedim
RTTI'yi
disable
etme
imkanı var
compiler
switch'leriyle
bu arada
ben de
bir soru
sorayım
hem Cengizan'a
hem diğer
arkadaşlarıma
sizce
neden böyle
bir switch'i
gerekli
görüyorlar
niye
RTTI'yi
devre dışı
bırakmak
isteyelim
bravo
olsan
performans
çünkü
normalde
C++'ın
şöyle bir
mantığı
var
değil mi
eğer
bir şeyi
kullanmıyorsanız
onun maliyetini
ödemeyeceksiniz
ben
seneler önce
C++ anlatırken
bu
Java
C Sharp
grubuyla bir
karşılaştırma
yaparken
şöyle bir
analoji
oluşturmuştum
halen
geçerli
olduğunu
bilmiyorum
ama
gördüm ki
şimdi siz bir
otele gidiyorsunuz
otelde
check-in
yapıyorsunuz
otel ücreti
diyelim ki
şu anda
Avrupa standartlarına
göre ne olsun
150 euro
olsun
otele
gittiniz
150 euro
ödeyeceksiniz
check-out
yapıyorsunuz
size bir
hesap geliyor
300 euro
ediyorsunuz
hani
150 euro
ben niye
300 euro
ödüyorum
işte diyor ki
bu gerçek değil
bir anoloji
sadece
odanızda diyor
minibar vardı
ama diyorsunuz
ben minibarı
kullanmıyorum
kullanmadım
olsun
biz kullansınız
kullanmasınız da
minibardaki
bütün içeceklerin
ücretini alıyoruz
efendim
sauna vardı
ama ben
saunadan
faydalanmadım
olsun
onun parasını
da ekliyorum
işte
C++'da
C Sharp
Java gibi
arkadaşlar
dillerin
farkını
biraz buna
benzetiyorlar
şimdi
o C Sharp
Java gibi
diller
kötü diller
olduğu için
demiyorum
tabii öyle
söylemek
mümkün değil
çok da
iyi tasarlanmış
diller
fakat o
dillerde
önemli olan
programcının
orada
neyse
üretkenliği
programcının
verimliliği
dil tamamen
ona göre
tasarlanmış
ama
C++'da
odak noktası
programcının
prodüktivitesi
verimliliği
değil
programın
üretkenliği
normalde o yüzden
C++'da
eğer kullanmıyorsan
maliyet sıfır
bunun dışında
kalan sayılı örneklerden
biri
işte bu
dynamic
yazdı
şimdi o soruya
geri dönelim
önce ben
sorumu tekrar
edeyim
sonra da
Oğuzhan Bey'in
sorusuna cevap vereyim
neden böyle bir
switch var
diye sormuştum
böyle bir switch
var
çünkü
arkadaşlar
derleyici bilemez ki
birden fazla
kaynak dosya
da olduğu için
ne olacak
bir kaynak dosya
ederlerken
o type info
nesnelerini
oluşturacak
bir kod üretcek
randayman başında
type info
nesneleri
oluşturulacak
polymortik
sınıflar için
ama siz peşin peşin
ben
RTTI
kullanmak
istemiyorum
derseniz
ona göre
kod üretecek
Oğuzhan diyor ki
yalnızca
type ID
ve dynamic
kesti mi
etkiler
evet sadece
type ID
ve dynamic
kesti
etkiler
yani
virtual
dispatch'ten
faydalanmanızı
arkadaşlar
engellemiyor
size kendi
compiler'ınızın
bu switch'lerini
bakabilirsiniz
bundan da bahsettiğimize göre
şimdi günün
büyük başlığını
atalım
ama önce bir
yoklamamızı
yapalım
aslında her terste
yapmam isteniyor
ama bu
kurumlar
talep ediyor
kurumla adına
katılanlar için
Alihan Bostur
Çağrı
Cengiz Anbarlı
Deniz Akkuş
Fatih Sevencan
İbrahim Özer
Kağan Canşit
Kave
Nematipur
Mehmet Karsima
Meriç Durçan
Medan Akduygu
Muhammed Yusuf Kapıkaya
Mutlak Bulak
Nazım
Mama Dili
Oğuzhan Esin
Rasul
Mamato
ve Samet
Şengel
teşekkür ediyorum
canlı katılanlara
arkadaşlar
şimdi büyük başlığımız
exception handling
benim kişisel deneyimim şu
C++'da değil sadece
genel olarak
programlamada
yanlış ya da
eksik öğrenilen
tipik
araçlardan biri
exception handling
ne olduğundan
tutun
bir kod
ne zaman
exception göndermeli
göndermemeli
bir exception
nasıl yakalanmalı
yakalanmalı mı
yakalanmamalı mı
çok sayıda
sorunun cevabı
ortalama
bir programcı
tarafından
yanlış
öğrenilmiş
ya da yanlış
anlaşılmış
oluyor
o yüzden
arkadaşlar
bu konuyu
iyi öğrenmekte
fayda var
şimdi
konunun bir
kesin gerçekleri var
yani
tartışmaya
mahal bırakmayan
eskilerin tabiriyle
bir de
değerli arkadaşlar
yani tamamen
programcıdan programcıya
değişebilecek
subjektif
ya da
programı
nasıl tasarladığınızda
ilgili
değişebilen
parçaları da var
onları da
birbirinden
ayırmak
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
aslında
exception
handling
bence
error
handling
dediğimiz
konunun
patlaştıklarından
biri
yani
asıl ilk olarak
biz neyi
öğrenmeliyiz
neyin
farkındalığına
sahip olmalıyız
error handling
ne demek
derken de
o zaman
burada
error
derken
kastedilen ne
ondan
bahsetmemiz
gerekiyor
burada
error
ya da
error handling
derken
kastedilen ne
ilk önce
oradan
başlayalım
çünkü
bakın
ben olsam
şöyle söylemeyi
tercih ederdim
error handling
yapmanın
birden fazla
yolu var
bu yollardan biri
exception
handling
bazen
exception
handling
en iyi seçim
bazen
exception
handling
yapmaya
iznimiz
olmayabilir
bazen de
exception
handling
o ya da
bu nedenden
tercih edilmeyebilir
başka
hata
işleme
türkçe karşılığı
olarak ben bunu
kullanacağım
error handling
için
hata işleme
terimini
kullanacağım
başka hata
işleme
yollarına
bakabiliriz
o zaman
önce
burada
kastedilen
error handling
error'ün
ne olduğunu
bir
konuşalım
arkadaşlar
burada
kastedilen
runtime
hataları
şimdi
ilk
edinmemiz
gereken
bilgi
şu iki
kategoriyi
birbirinden
ayırmak
bir
runtime
error var
bir de
programlama
hataları
var
ikisi
genelde
birbiriyle
karıştırılabiliyor
arkadaşlar
programlama
hataları
derken
baz edilen
şu
sizin
yazdığınız
kod
küfür eder gibi
oldu
biraz daha yumuşak
sizin yazdığınız
kodda
bir hata
var
yani
kod yanlış
olduğu için
kod
beklenen işi
yapamıyor
mesela
bir fonksiyon
var
bu fonksiyon
girişi yapmakla
görevli
fakat
siz
bu fonksiyonun
kodunda
yanlış
bir şeyler
yazmışsınız
kod yanlış
olduğu için
fonksiyon
yapması gereken
işi
yapamıyor
böyle hataları
runtime
hatalarından
ayırmak için
yani bizim
o
errorlerimizden
ayırmak için
böyle hatalara
popüler olarak
programming
errors
deniyor
mesela
fonksiyonumuzun
arkadaşlar
bir iş yaparken
bir dosyayı
diyelim ki
bir database
dosyasını
açması gerektiğini
düşünelim
fakat
buradaki
algoritma
gereği
önce bizim
database
dosyasının
ismini elde
etmemiz
gerekiyor
onlarca
farklı database
dosyaları var
bizim önce
database
dosyasını
bazı
lojikle
bir elde
etmemiz
gerekiyor
mesela bir yazıyı
bir yerden
alacağız
mesela bu yazı
database
yazısı
olsun
efendim
bir yerden
tarih bilgisini
alacağız
bu tarih bilgisini
yazıya dönüştüreceğiz
verili bir formatta
bu iki yazıyı
toplayacağız
sonuna
dot ekleyeceğiz
böylece bir dosya
ismi elde edeceğiz
ve o dosyayı
açacağız
fakat
diyelim ki
programcı
bu string
manipulation
kısmını
yanlış
yazmış
dolayısıyla
örneğin
olması gereken
bir underscore
karakteri yok
ya da
tarih formatı
yazıya
dönüştürürken
çok eski
şeklinde
olması
gerekirken
formatlamada
bir hata
yapmış
yazıda
yazı böyle
olmuş
dolayısıyla
dosya ismi
tutmadığı için
dosya
açılamıyor
şimdi
programlama
hatalarıyla
başa çıkmanın
yolu
bu değil
yani
runtime
hatalarıyla
baş etmek
ayrı bir
konu
ki oraya doğru
ilerliyoruz
zaten
ama
programlama
hatalarıyla
baş etmek
apayrı bir
konu
arkadaşlar
buradaki
programı
düzeltmenin
tek ve tek
bir doğru
yolu var
hatalı olan
kodu
bulacaksınız
o kodu
değiştireceksiniz
ve yeniden
derleyeceksiniz
recompile
edeceksiniz
yani
bir yerde
bug
fixing
yapacaksınız
kod yanlış
kodu
düzeltmeden
yapabileceğimiz
bir şey
yok
peki
şimdi
soru
eğer
programlama
hatası
derken
kastedilen
buysa
programlama
hatalarıyla
baş etmenin
tipik
araç
seti
ne
cevap
bravo
çağrı
assertion
bravo
hocaynizden
assertion
ları
o zaman
programlama
hatalarından
bahsediyorsak
bizim işimiz
assertion
larla
c++
bahsetmiyorum
sadece
assertion
ları
bu tarz
dillerde
iki ayrı
kategoriye
ayırıyoruz
biri
static
assertions
arkadaşlar
diğeri
dynamic
assertions
yani
aslında
buradaki
statik ve
dynamic
terimlere
birçok yerde
olduğu gibi
statik olan
compile time'a
ilişkin
arkadaşlar
dinamik olanlar
runtime'a
ilişkin
şimdi
static
assertion
şu demek
hatırlayalım
c'de de anlatmış
oluyorum
c kursuna katılmış
arkadaşlar
hatırlayacaklar
bizim yazdığımız
yanlış kod
compile time'da
derneme sırasında
bazı araçlarla
anlaşılıyor
işte mesela
c++'da
static
assert
declaration
dediğimiz bir bildirim
var henüz
görmedik
jenerik programlama
tarafına
geçtiğimizde
göreceğiz
c'de
başta bu
yoktu
ve ben
C'nin o günlerinde
özlüyorum
C'nin
böyle nasıl söyleyeyim
ham C'yi olduğu
yani
C99 falan bile yok
C99
C11 yok
arkadaşlar
ilk
standart zamanları
çünkü
C'ye de daha
sonradan
static
assertion
eklendi
fakat
C'ye
static
assert
eklendi
ama
static
assertten
önce de
böyle bir
ihtiyat
vardı
o dönemde
C kodu
yazanlar
var mı
ya da
halen
kullanan
var mı
bilmiyorum
çok ilginç
şeyler
kullanıyorduk
C'de
mesela
diyelim ki
bizim kodun
doğru olması
için
int türünün
size of
değerinin
diyelim ki
ikiden
büyük olması
gereksin
yapılan
iyilere bakın
şimdi
aslında eğlenceli
puzzle gibi
ben öyle bir
kod yazacağım ki
yazdığım
kod
eğer bu
koşul
doğru
değilse
compile time'da
hata oluşturacak
tabii ki
günümüzde
bunun için
modern araçlar
var
en başında da
static
assert
deklarayışım
geliyor zaten
şimdi
bakın bakın
neler yapıyorduk
şimdi
öyle
sentaks
kuralları
var ki
o üstünde
onları
violate
ettiğinizde
derleyici
derlemiyor
diagnostik
vermek
zorunda
mesela
eğer bir
extension
söz konusu
değilse
bu koddaki
hata ne
yani
sentaks
hatası ne
dizi boyutu
sıfır
olamaz
öyle değil mi
peki
şimdi bakın
o zaman
karşılaştırma
operatörlerinin
bunun
c kodu
olduğunu
düşünün
karşılaştırma
operatörleri
de zaten
sıfır ya da
bir değeri
üretiyor
değil mi
size of
int
arkadaşlar
örneğin
büyük
iki
ifadesini
bu dizinin
boyutu
yaparsam
bu ifade
doğru
doğru olduğu için
değeri bir
ben bir elemanlı
bir
dizi tanımlamış
oluyorum
ama bu ifade
yanlış olsaydı
sentaks
hatası
olacaktı
bakın bakın
bu kadar basit
dediği
şimdi
güzelliğe
bakın
arkadaşlar
tabi
bu iyi bir yol
olmaz
niye iyi bir yol
ne yapacaksın
bu halk tabiriyle
bu diziyi
eve mi götüreceksin
doğruysa
ortada bir isim
var
şu var
bu var
onun yerine
biraz daha iyisi
şunu yapıyorduk
bakın bakın
type alias declaration
arkadaşlar
bu bir tür mü
evet
o zaman ben
böyle bir türe
eşisim verebilirim
değil mi
c'de
türe eşisim vermenin
yolu ne
type def bildirimi
type def bildiriminin
golden rule'u ne
hangi türe eşisim
vereceksen
o türden bir değişken
tanımla
başına
type def getir
ve değişken ismini
type alias olarak
değiştir
inta
dört
şimdi
inta dört
dört elemanlı
int dizi türünün
eş ismi oldu
yani burada
tanımladığım bir nesne yok
bu sadece
bir türe eşisim
bildirimi
rasul
siz bana bu konuda
bir soru sormuştunuz
hatırlıyor musunuz
o zaman
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
ben
sıfır elemanlı
bir dizi türüne de
type def bildirimiyle
eşisim
verebilirim
ama böyle bir eşisim
bildirimi
bilim kurallarını
ihlal ettiği için
sentaks hatası olacak
o zaman
ifademi de
buraya yazsın
size of int
büyüktür
iki böyle
çok sayıda
c'de
hile vardı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
tabi ki bu isim
çakışmasını
engellemek istiyorsanız
onun da ayrı
yolları var
ve nasıl
static assertion
derken
tekrar
bu konuyu
çok fazla
dağıtmadan
konumuza
geri dönelim
static assertion
derken
kast edilen
compile time'de
yapılan
kontroller
arkadaşlar
aa
bu arada
işte bu
compile time'de
yapılan
kontroller
açısından
c++
müthiş bir
dil
çünkü
çok sayıda
araç var
bu konuya ilişkin
c++
standartıyla
gelen
konseptler
zaten
jenerik
programlama
tarafında
compile time
kontrollerini
yapmaya
yönelik
dynamic
assertion ise
run time'de
yapılan
doğrulamalar
ve
biliyorsunuz
dynamic
assertion'ın
alfabesi
başlangıcıda
assert
makrosu
c'den gelen
aslında
az önceki
kodda da
kodlardan
birinde de
işte kullandığım
benim
assert
makrosu
c'de
c++'da da
dynamic
assertion'ın
en tipik
örneği
ben
herkesin
assert
makrosunun
ne olduğunu
bildiğini
varsayıyorum
c'de çok detaylı
anlatmış oluyorum
assert
makrosu
nedir
nasıl kullanılır
nasıl
implement edilir
tepik
bir derleyici
tarafından
ama
bunu
şöyle
düşünün
değil mi
aslında
burada
arkadaşlar
bir
koşullu
derleme
conditional
compiling
konutu var
eğer
and
debug
makrosu
define
edilmemişse
bu bir
fonksiyonel
makro
ingilizcesiyle
functional
makro
bu fonksiyonel
açıldığında
aslında
arkadaşlar
bu ifadenin
doğru olup
olmadığı
sınanıyor
eğer ifade
doğru değilse
efendim
hata akımına
assertion
failed
ifade
yazılıyor
hangi
dosyadın
kaçıncı
satırında
olduğu
vesaire
şimdi
konuyu
çok da
dağıtmak
istemiyorum
şimdi
o zaman
biz başa
geri dönelim
programlama
hataları
yazdığımız
kodun
yanlış
olması
nedeni
oluşan
hatalar
düzeltmenin
yolu
kodu
değiştirmek
buradaki
araçlarımız
arkadaşlar
assertion'lar
gerek
static
assertion
gerek
dynamic
assertion
ve tabii ki
bir de
debugger
programlar
ama
şimdi
gelelim
programlama
hatalarına
değil
runtime
hatalarına
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyon
burada
temel birim
her zaman
bir fonksiyon
bir fonksiyonumuz
var
fonksiyon
sınıfın
bir üye
fonksiyonu
olabilir
bir
free
function
olabilir
sınıfın
statik
ya da
non
statik
ve
fonksiyonu
olabilir
bu fonksiyonun
yapması
gereken
bir iş
var
buraya
dikkat
bu fonksiyonun
yapması
gereken
bir iş
var
ve
bu fonksiyon
o yapması
gereken
işi
yapamadığını
kendi
koduyla
saptıyor
yani
başarılı
olamayacak
işlemi
o ya da
bu nedenle
onu konuşacağız
yapma
imkanı
kalmamış
bunu
detect ediyor
ve burada
zaten
işini
yapamadığı
zaman
ne yapması
gerektiğini
biliyorsa
bunu lokal
olarak
kendisi
hallediyor
ama
çok çok
çok büyük
çoğunlukla
bir fonksiyon
işini
yapamadığında
karar verme
yetkisi
kendisinde
değil
karar verme
yetkisi
onu çağıran
kodda
ilk olarak
bu durumda
fonksiyon
diyor ki
ben bir hata
durumuna
düştüm
işimi
yapamıyorum
fakat
bunu lokal
olarak da
halledemiyorum
beni çağıranı
bu durumdan
haberdar
etmek istiyorum
bir
erör
durumu
oluştu
arkadaşlar
bu
erör
durumunu da
çok iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
yani burada
erörden
bahsedilen
olası
durum
değil
olağan dışı
durum
mesela az önceki
örneğe geri dönelim
dosya örneğine
arkadaşlar
yine aynı işi
yapan fonksiyon
az önce bir örnek
vermiştim ya
fakat
bütün kod
doğru yazılmış
fakat
açılması
gereken
dosya
serverda
neredeyse
silinmiş
sorumsuz
şahsiyetin
biri
iş
teref
öyle diyormuş
şerefsizin
biri
dosyayı
silmiş
ne yapsın
dosya silindiği için
yok
açılamıyor
normalde böyle bir şeyin
olmaması gerekiyor
programın genel
lojik yapısının
dışında kabul edilebilecek
bir durum
dışsal
şimdi fonksiyon
dosyayı açamadığı zaman
işini de yapamamış
olacak
ve kendisini
çağıran koddan
bu durumu
haberdar
çağıran kodu
bu durumdan haberdar
etmesi gerekiyor
zaten ne yapması
gerektiğini bilse
ortada bir problem yok
o işi yapacak
işte
error handling
derken
hastedilen
bu hataların
handlingi
ele alınması
bu hataların
nasıl işleneceği
yani bir fonksiyon
işini
yapamadığı zaman
ne yapacak
kendisini
çağıran
kod ya da
kodları
bu durumdan
nasıl haberdar edecek
bu konuya
genelde
error handling
deniyor
ve error handling
yine bir
belki
alt kategorisi
yani error handling
yapmanın
yollarından biri
ama tek yol değil
exception handling
burada şimdi
şöyle bir tanıma da
ihtiyaç duyulduğunu
düşünüyorum
iyi de
bir fonksiyonun
işini yapamaması
ne demek
arkadaşlar
bu tipik olarak
şöyle
formülüze
ediliyor
buraya dikkat
preconditions
postconditions
invariants
şimdi burası
biraz belki
size soyut gelebilir
ama zaman içinde
somutlaştırmamız
gerekiyor
fonksiyonlar
söz konusu olduğu zaman
en kolay
anlamamız gereken
postconditions
yani
fonksiyon
işini
yaptığında
oluşması gereken
durum
eğer
bir fonksiyon
bu postconditions'ı
yani fonksiyon
çağrıldıktan sonra
olması gereken
durumu
sağlayamıyorsa
bu bir
error demektir
mesela
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
vektör sınıfının
pushback
fonksiyonu
burada
fonksiyon
vektöre
bir
sondan
eleman ekleyecek
dinamik diziye
elemanın
eklenmesi
demek
vektörün
başarılı bir şekilde
bu operasyonu
tamamlaması
ve vektördeki
eleman sayısının
bir fazla olması
ve vektördeki
son elemanın
bizim eklediğimiz
değerde olması
demek
eğer fonksiyon
bir nedenden
dolayı
bu postconditions'ı
sağlayamıyorsa
bu işi
yapamamış
demektir
bu bir hata
durumudur
preconditions'ı
ise
ikiye ayırmakta
fayda var
genelde
en zor anlaşılan
kısım
preconditions
preconditions'ı
fonksiyon
a fonksiyon
çağrıldığında
oluşması
gereken
durum
oluşmuş mu
bu
sorunun
aslında
muhatapı
fonksiyonu
çağıran kod
mesela bakın
en basit örnek
karakök fonksiyonu
siz
karakök fonksiyonumuz
olsa
standart
kütüphanelik
karakök fonksiyonundan
bahsetmiyorum
ve burada
karmaşık sayılar
kompleks sayılar
vesaire
yoksa
burada beklenen
fonksiyonun
dokümentasyonuyla
da bunun
belirlenmesi
gerekiyor
buraya gelen
sayının
arkadaşlar
bir
pozitif sayı
olması
ya da sıfır
gerekiyor
negatif sayılar
için
karakökün
tanımlı olmadığını
düşünelim
kompleks sayı
aritmetiğinden
bahsetmiyorum
o zaman
eğer
buraya gelen
sayı
bu olabilecek
en basit örnek
arkadaşlar
buraya gelen
sayı
eğer negatif
bir gerçek sayıysa
fonksiyonun
preconditions'ı
oluşmamış
demektir
sağlanmamış
bu da fonksiyonun
işi yapmasına
engel bir durum
artık fonksiyonun
işi yapamayacağı
kesinleşti
yalnız bakın
preconditions
kısmı
error and link
ile ilişkisi
ayrı
şimdi post
conditions'ı
oluşturamazsanız
error and link
mecburi
başka bir yol
yok
ama
preconditions
sağlanmıyorsa
yani
fonksiyonu
çağıran
kod
bunu
gerçekleştirememişse
burada iki tane
farklı yaklaşım var
hata işlemi açısından
birine
arkadaşlar
narrow contract
diyorlar
İngilizce'de
duydunuz muhterimi
duyan var mı
narrow
dar anlamında
narrow contract
diğerine de
wide
ya da
broad
contract
diyorlar
narrow contract
aslında
pratik
halk tarzı
ifadeyle
şu demek
efendim
ben
dokümante
ettim
senin bu
fonksiyona
iyi bu
fonksiyonu
çağıran
kod
bu fonksiyona
negatif
değer
gelmemeliydi
sen
buna uymak
zorundasın
ben bunu
bir hata
olarak
görmüyorum
işimi
yapıyorum
eğer negatif
sayı
gelirse de
sonucuna
herkes
katlanmak
zorunda
tipik olarak
tanımsız
davranış olacak
eski artiden
bahsetmiyorum
anlaşıldı mı
narrow contract
diye buna
diyorlar
broad contract
şu demek
ya da
wide contract
arkadaşlar
hayır
fonksiyonu
çağrına
bırakmıyorum
fonksiyon
reconditions'ın
sağlanıp
sağlanmadığını
kendisi
kontrol ediyor
mesela
bir soru
soracağım
hatırlayacak
mısınız
arkadaşlar
mesela
string sınıfının
arkadaşlar
insert fonksiyonunu
düşünün
string fonksiyonunun
insert fonksiyonlarından
birini düşünün
insert işleminin
yapılması için
indeksin doğru
olması gerekiyor
değil mi
mesela yazı
efendim
Cengiz Han
yazısıysa
karakterin
ya da karakterlerin
insert edileceği
indeks olarak
ben
Cengiz Han'da
8 karakter var
indeksini
insert fonksiyonuna
geçsem
burada bu
geçerli bir
indeks olmadığına göre
fonksiyonun
preconditions'ı
karşılanmamış olur
değil mi
Cengiz Han Bey
mesela
standart kütüphanenin
insert fonksiyonu
burada
wide contract
broad contract
kullanıyor
yani
bize bırakmıyor
ama birçok yerde de
standart kütüphanenin
standart fonksiyonları
narrow contract
kullanıyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
preconditions kısmına
geldiğimiz zaman
narrow contract
ya da wide contract
olduğu tamamen
kütüphaneye
stratejiye
şuna buna
bağlı
dolayısıyla
gelmesi gereken
argümanlar
olması gereken
değer ya da
değerlerde
değilse
ben bunu
bir error
olarak
beni çağıran
koda
bildirmeli miyim
sorusunun cevabı
it depends
Ahmet
bildirmeyi
tercih edebilir
wide contract'ı
tercih etmiş
olabilir
efendim
Mehmet
narrow contract'ı
tercih etmiş
olabilir
ama precondition'ın
bir başka
biçimi var ki
bence bu da
karıştırılıyor
fonksiyonun
çağırdığı fonksiyonun
precondition'ları
arkadaşlar
o zaman
ondan ben
sorumluyum
yani örneğin
şimdi
fu isimli
bir fonksiyon
kendi içinde
bar fonksiyonla
çağrı yapıyor
ama
bar fonksiyonla
bir argüman
gönderecek
bu argüman
olan
olacak ifadenin
değerini
hesaplaması
gerekiyor
ama
hesaplayamıyor
böylece
arkadaşlar
barın precondition'ını
sağlayamadığı için
işini
yapamıyor
yani
sağlayamadığını
bile bile
bu fonksiyonu
çağırsa
hata durumunu
yaymış olacak
anladınız mı
tamam
şimdi
burada anlamadığımız
bir şey var mı
error demek
bir
post conditions'ın
met olmaması
yani
karşılanmaması
iki
fonksiyon içinde yapılan
fonksiyon çağrılarında
kullanılacak argümanların
precondition'ı
sağlamaması
sağlayamaması
üç
narrow ya da
wide contract
kullanılıp
kullanılmadığına
bağlı olarak
fonksiyona gelen
argümanların
fonksiyonun
istediği
doküman
ettiği
tipik olarak
aralıkta
ya da özellikte
olmaması
bunlar
error durumu
sadece
bu
preconditions
kısmında
bir
ne var
programcıya
bağlı
bir
seçim var
ama
bu
invariant nedir
arkadaşlar
invariant
ne demek
tipik olarak
sınıfların
public
üye fonksiyonları
için
geçerli bir kavram
sınıfların
public
member
fonksiyonları
için
gereken bir
kavram
şimdi
örneğin
bizim
fonksiyonumuz
arkadaşlar
bağlı liste
link list
veri
ne diyelim
unuttum
kelime
data structure
ile ilgili
onu temsil eden
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
olsun
ben
sembolik olarak
yazıyorum
işte listin
örneğin
ne fonksiyonu
insert
isimli
ya da
pushback
isimli
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
sınıflar
söz konusu
olduğu zaman
sınıfların
tipik olarak
invariantları
var
burada
invariantın
türküye nasıl
çevirmedi
siz daha iyi
bir öneride
bulunabilirsiniz
değişmez
her zaman
doğru olacak
mesela
bağlı liste
örneğini
vermem
tesadüfi
değil
bu örnek
üstünden
anlatmak
çok kolay
çünkü
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon
işini
yapmadan önce
sınıf
nesnesinin
geçerli
durumunu
biliyor
ve işini
yaptıktan sonra
sadece işini
yapmakla kalmıyor
sınıf nesnesinin
geçerli
durumunu
İngilizcesiyle
valid state'ini
devam
ettiriyor
ondan
emin
yani örneğin
siz bir
üye fonksiyonu
implemente
ederken
fonksiyonun
kodu
çalıştığında
ben o işi
yaptım
deyip
geçerseniz
ve
sınıf nesnesini
bir
İngilizcesini
invalid
state'de
bırakırsanız
bu kabul
edebilir
bir durum
değil
mesela
invalid
state
ne
olabilir
arkadaşlar
son derece
basit
daha çok
sınıfın
data
memberlarıyla
ilgili
mesela
şimdi bu
sınıfın
data
memberlarını
düşünün
sınıfın
elemanlarından
bir tanesi
size t
msize
sınıfın
elemanlarından
bir tanesi
pointer to
node
efendim
p first
çok basit
örnek üstünden
gösterelim
arkadaşlar
valid state
şöyle değil mi
olmak zorunda
eğer
liste boşsa
p first
null pointer
bulacak
liste boş
değilse
ilk düğümün
node'un
adresini
tutacak
efendim
msize
liste boşsa
sıfır
olacak
listede
n tane
varsa
msize
değeri
n olacak
e şimdi
bu operasyonda
siz
bu
invariantı
invariantları
sadece bir örnek
koruyamıyorsanız
işi yaptığınızda
invariantlar
yine
ingilizcesiyle
hold etmiyorsa
artık o sınıf
nesnesi
geçerli bir durumda
olmayacak
o zaman
şöyle diyelim
tipik tanımı
kullanalım
error
nedir
fonksiyonun
işini
yapamaması
durumudur
üstlendiği görevi
yapamadığı
ve
bununla
arkadaşlar
lokal olarak
baş edemediği
durumlardır
burada
bundan
kendisini
çağıran
kodların
haberdar edilmesine
error
handling
diyoruz
error
de
precondition'ların
post
condition'ların
sağlanamaması
ya da
invariantların
arkadaşlar
artık
bir
valid state'i
işaret edecek
halde
tutulamaması
anlaşılıyor
buraya kadar
epey yol katettik
yani
error derken
runtime
bunu kastediyoruz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
geldik
error
handling'e
işte
biz
fonksiyonun
kodu
işini
yapamadığı
zaman
fonksiyonun
kendisini
çağıran
kodu ya da
kodları
bu durumdan
haberdar
etmesine
error
handling
diyoruz
şimdi
error handling
derken
bunu da
ikiye ayırmamız
gerekiyor
birine
geleneksel
hata işlemi
biçimleri
yöntemleri
metodolojisi
diyebiliriz
arkadaşlar
hadi bunu
benim tabirimle
traditional
error handling
diyelim
diğerine de
daha modern
bir araç seti
olan
exception
handling
diyelim
modern
programlama
dilleri
C++
tahil
ama
C'de
maalesef
yok
birbirine
benzer
sentaksa
ve semantik
yapıya sahip
birbiriyle
tamamen
aynı
olmasa da
hata işlemi
error handling
konusunda
dilin içine
gömülü
exception
handling
diye popüler
olarak söylenen
bu terimde
çok yanlış
anlaşılabiliyor
bir
araç
seti
içeriyor
arkadaşlar
bu görece olarak
yani programlamanın
tarihsel gelişimine
bakarsanız
exception
handling
şüphesiz
traditional
error
handling
e göre
daha
modern
bir araç
daha sonra
oluşturulmuş
bir araç
seti
programlama
deneyim olarak
arkadaşlar
önce
traditional
error
handling
ne olduğunu
nasıl yapıldığını
öğrenmemizi
hatırlamamız
gerekiyor
çünkü
exception
handling
buna bir
alternatif
ve bazı
durumlarda
çok iyi
bir alternatif
yani
traditional
ya da
conventional
error
handling
dezavantajlarına
karşı
bazı
avantajlar
sunan
önemli bir
alternatif
o zaman önce
traditional
error
handling
ne
neden
traditional
error
handling
ile yetinmek
istemiyoruz
da
elimizde
bir de
exception
handling
dediğimiz
araç
seti
var
önce
orayı
iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
birbirinden
farklı
görünse de
traditional
error
handling
iki tane
tipik
görüntüsü
var
biri
fonksiyonun
işini
yapamaması
durumunda
işini
yapamadığına
ilişkin
bir hata
değerini
kendisine
çağıran
koda
geri dönüş
değeri
mekanizmasıyla
iletmek
örneğin
arkadaşlar
int
do
something
params
diyor ki
fonksiyonun
dökümentasyonu
örneğin
eğer fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
eksi
birse
bu tabi ki
konvensyon
kütüphaneden
kütüphaneye
değişebilir
bu fonksiyonun
işini
yapamamış
demektir
efendim
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
null
pointer
ise
bu fonksiyonun
işini
yapamamış
demektir
yani
geleneksel
error
handling
en tipik
aracı
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
hata
kodu
olması
ya da bir
hata
olup
olmadığını
gösteren
bir
değer
olması
ve
belirli bir
değerin
hata
error
anlamına
gelmesi
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeriyle
ben işimi
yaptım
Allah'a şükür
ya da ben işimi
yapamadım
anlamında
bir
değer
döndürmesi
bu
hepimizin
zaten
si'den
alışık
olduğumuz
benim
tabirimle
başımızın
belası
error
handling
yolu
neden
başımızın
belası
dediğimi
birazdan ayrıntılı
açıklamaya başlayacağım
ama buna benzer bir yol
daha var
kim söyleyecek
adanın
çağıran koda
iletilmesinde
sinin standart
kütüphanesinin de
destek verdiği
özellikle bu
unix news
tarafında
sistem programlama
yaptıysanız
ortalık
bundan
geçilmiyor
bir yol daha var
Resul
Cengiz Han
Ali Han
nedir bu yol
Erno
bravo
arkadaşlar
global bir hata
değişkeni olur
yani ben programlama
dilinden bağımsız
anlatır gibi yapayım
bu global hata
değişkeninin
bir değeri
olur
ve
bir fonksiyon
hataya düştüğünde
işini
yapamadığında
geri dönüş
değerini
kullanmak
yerine
ya da
bu da çok
yaygın
her ikisi
birden
gider
arkadaşlar
Erno
değişkenini
belirli bir
değerle
set eder
böylece
fonksiyonu
çağıran kod
çağırdıktan
sonra
Erno
değişkeninin
değerine
bakar
Erno
değişkeninin
normalde
hatasızlık
durumunda
olması gereken
değer sıfır
eğer sıfır
değilse
en son
çağırdığı
fonksiyonun
Erno'yu
set ettiğini
anlar
ve hatta
Erno'nun
hangi değerle
set edildiğine
bağlı olarak
arkadaşlar
ne yapar
hatanın
neyle ilgili
olduğunu da
anlayabilir
mesela
standart kütüphanenin
f-open
fonksiyonu
her ikisini
birden
kullanıyor
değil mi
arkadaşlar
mesela
bakın
şimdi
ipot yazalım
beraber
file
yıldız
f
eşittir
cst'de
aorita
dahil edelim
c kodu
olduğunu
düşündüğümüz
bunun
file
yıldız
f
f-open
not
exist
nokta
txt
r
mesela bakınız
f-open
fonksiyonu
her iki yolda
kullanılıyor
bazı fonksiyonlar
sadece Erno'yu
kullanıyor
bazı fonksiyonlar
sadece geri dönüş
değerini
kullanıyor
örneğin
f-open
her ikisini de
kullanıyor
if
f-eşit
tabi c'de
null makrosunu
kullanıyoruz
printf
cannot
open
file
ama
aynı
zamanda
arkadaşlar
p-error
hata
işte
burada
Erno'nun
değerini de
alabilirdim
Erno'nun
değerini
stl
error
fonksiyonuna
argüman olarak
gönderebilirdim
vesaire
şimdi ben
Erno kısmını
anlatmayayım
ama en azından
arkadaşlar
buraya kadar
bir derleyelim
burada
şu makroyu
istiyor
standart
C fonksiyonlarının
bir kısmı
için
benim
derleyicim
gördünüz değil mi
bakın
p-error
arkadaşlar
no such file
or
directory
Erno'nun
set edildiği
anlamına
geliyor
şimdi
buraya geri dönelim
baya bir ilerledik
o zaman
tekrar edecek
olursak
geleneksel
hata
işleme
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
mekanizmasıyla
arkadaşlar
ya da
global bir
hata
değişkenini
set etmesiyle
hatanın
çağıran koda
bildirilmesi
tipik olarak
iyi ama
burada
kötü olan
kötü olan ne
yani
geleneksel
hata işleme
mekanizmasının
eksik kalan
ya da hoşumuza
gitmeyen
tarafları
tabiri caizse
daha
devrimci
revolutionary
bir
mekanizm
mekanizmanın
aranmasının
arkasındaki
sebepler ne
ben
kendime göre
bir önem
sırası
gözetmeden
tek tek
söyleyeceğim
arkadaşlar
bir kere
burada
belki
7-8 tane
madde yazacağım
siz katıldıklarınıza
katılıyorum
deyin
katılmadıklarınıza
katılmıyorum
deyin
bir kere
bu kesinlikle
forcing
bir mekanizma
yani
zorlayıcı
bir mekanizma
değil
zaten
C kodlarında
en fazla hata da
buradan geliyor
değil mi
yani
örneğin
malloc
başarılı
olursa
allocate
ettiği
bernek
bloğunun
adresine
döndürüyor
ama
başarısızlık
durumunda
null pointer
döndürüyor
kardeşim sen
mallocu çağırdığında
geri dönüş
değerini
kontrol etmezsen
malloc
null pointer
döndürmüş
olmasına rağmen
elde ettiğin
adresi
sanki
allocate edilmiş
bernek bloğunun
adresi olarak
kullanırsan
orada
ipin ucunu
kaçırmış
olursun
arkadaşlar
bir de burada
şöyle bir nokta var
siz
runtime hatasını
müdahale
etmediğiniz zaman
etmeniz gereken
bir yerde
o hata
yayılıyor
başka katmanlara
yani o hatayı
artık
anlamak
tespit etmek
çok daha
zor hale geliyor
çünkü bir anda
örneğin bir tanımsız
davranış oluştuğunda
all bets are
off
zorlayıcı bir
mekanizma değil
bu bence son derece
önemli
yani
örneğin bir fonksiyon
işini yapamadım
diyor
ama siz onu
duymak istemiyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
ne yapacak
bu durumda
bu
en önemli
madde olmasa da
önemli maddelerden
birim
bence en önemli
madde şu
geleneksel hata
işlemede
insanları
canından
bezdiren
noktalar
bence
şunlar
bir
arkadaşlar
kodlarda
en çok
ne var
bu nasıl
bir soru
if deyimleri
var örneğin
arkadaşlar
ortalık
if deyimleri
ile
doğru
şimdi bakınız
bu if deyimleri
bir yerde programlamanın
olmazsa
olmazı
diğer taraftan da
başımızın belası
neden
programlamanın
olmazsa
olmazı
bunu açıklamaya
gerek yok
neden
başımızın
belası
dediğime
değinmek istiyorum
arkadaşlar
bir
hangi if deyimi
algoritmanın
bir parçası
hangi if deyimi
bir fonksiyonun
işini yapamaması
durumunda
alternatif
yani bir
lojik if deyimleri var
algoritmanın
gerektirdiği
öyle değil mi
bir de
örneğin
mallog
işini yapamıyorsa
hatayı işken
if deyimleri var
bunlar iç içe
geçmiş durumda
geleneksel hata işleme
metodolojisinin
kullanılması durumda
koda bakıyorsunuz
hangi kodun
hata işlemeye
yönelik olduğunu
hangi kodun
Türkçesiyle
iş görmeye
yönelik olduğunu
birbirinden
ayırt etmek
tabii ki
imkansız değil
ama zor
zahmetli
kafa karıştırıcı
öyle değil mi
oysa
hata işleyen
kodla
iş gören
kod
yani
error handling
koduyla
arkadaşlar
algoritmanın
kendi
implementasyon
kodu
birbirinden
ayrılsaydı
o zaman
kodu anlamak
son derece
kolay olacaktı
yani bence
geleneksel hata
işlemenin
en büyük
dezavantajlarından
biri
iş gören
kodla
arkadaşlar
iş gören
kodla
hata işleyen
kodun
iç içe
geçmiş olması
bilmiyorum
sizde böyle
düşünüyor musunuz
arkadaşlar
bir de
şimdi
kod kalitesini
düşüren
en temel
faktörlerden biri
tamam
iç içe geçti
hadi onu da
kabul ettik
mecburuz
arkadaşlar
test kodu
yazmak
ne kadar fazla
if deyimi
varsa
o kadar fazla
test kodu
yazmak
zorundasınız
her if
bir testin
case'lerinden
biri olacak
yani
if deyimlerinin
azaltılması
örneğin
en azından
algoritmadaki
if deyimini
azaltamazsınız
belki ama
tabi onu da
azaltmaya yönelik
teklifler olsa da
abartmamak gerekiyor
ama
hata işlemeye
yönelik
if deyimlerini
azaltırsanız
test aşamasında da
önemli avantajlar
elde edeceksiniz
öyle değil mi
şimdi burada
o zaman
önce birinci
soruya bakalım
daha devrimci
bir mekanizma
istiyorsak
ondan ne
talep edebiliriz
zorlayıcı
olsun
mesela hataya
müdahale edilmediği
zaman program
sonlansın
hata işlemiyor
onu
but
program sonlanıyor
terminate ediyor
iki
iş gören
kodla hata
işleyen kod
birbirine
geçmiş durumda
o zaman
daha devrimci
bir mekanizmadan
ne bekleyeceğiz
bunları birbirinden
ayıralım
peki
if deyimleri
testi
zorlaştırıyor
test süreçlerini
o zaman
if deyimleri
azalsın
ama nasıl
azalacak ki
şimdi
geleneksel hata
işlemenin
en büyük
dezavantajından
bahsedeceğim size
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonlar
tipik olarak
bir
call chain
içinde
çağrılıyorlar
yani örneğin
f1 fonksiyonu
f2
f2 fonksiyonu
f3
f3 fonksiyonu
nokta nokta nokta
f19'u
çağırıyor
yani böyle bir
call chain var
arkadaşlar
f19
kendi
kodunda
işini
yapamadığını
bitekte ediyor
ve lokal olarak
müdahale etme
şansı yok
kendisini
çağıran
koda
durumdan
haber verecek
ama kendisini
çağıran
kod hangisi
f18
ama f18
o da
emir kulu
müdahale
etkisine
sahip değil
o zaman
f19
dan aldığı
bilgiyi
f18
kendisini
çağıran
f17'ye
iletebilir
ama diyelim ki
burada karar
verme
yetkisi
yani bu iş
yapılamadığı zaman
ne yapılsın
bilgisi
çoğu zaman
call chain'deki
yukarıdaki
fonksiyonlarda
o zaman ne oluyor
biliyor musunuz
işte
tipik c kodu
o ona haber veriyor
ve
f10
programın
akışı
nokta nokta
f1'e gidiyor
f1
bakıyor ki
iş yapılamamış
bu durumda
ne yapılması
gerekiyorsa
kararı
f1 veriyor
şimdi işte
burada
asıl
devrimci atak
revolutionary
mekanizm
öyle bir şey olsun ki
f19
işini yapamadığını
anladığı zaman
yukarıdaki
kodları
bu durumdan
haberdar etsin
ama programın
akışı
f19'dan
kendisini
çağıran
koda değil
runtime'da
doğrudan
mesela diyelim ki
ta f19'dan
f1'e
gitsin
yani
yangını
söndürürken
kovaların
elden ele
taşınması
gibi
birbirlerine
böyle
if deyimleriyle
değerleri
iletmesinler
işte bence
exception
handling'in
getirdiği
en önemli
faydalardan biri
programın
çalışma
zamanında
programın
akışını
hatayı
tespit eden
koddan
hataya
müdahale
edecek
koda
göndermesi
arkadaşlar
ya
benim çağırdığım
fonksiyon
işi
yapamadığı
zaman
benim yapabileceğim
bir şey yok
ben karar verici
değilim
o zaman
niye ben
kontrol yapayım
bu durumda
düşünsenize
10 yerde
if deyimi
olmak yerine
sadece
hata olup
olmadığını
anlamak
f1'deki
bir kodda
olacak
bu da testi
son derece
kolaylaştıracak
arkadaşlar
daha da
bitmedi
şimdi bunlar
bir daha sayalım
en önemli
bence nedenler
yani zorlayıcı
bir mekanizma
yok
nasıl anlıyor
runtime ile
direkt hangisine
göndereceğini
vtable ile
alakası var mı
bunun yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakınız
c++'da
bir iş yapılıyorsa
c'de
hayli hayli yapılır
yani
c makineye
daha yakın
bu açıdan
bakarsak
normalde
bir fonksiyonun
kodu çalışırken
programın
akışını
call chain'de
daha yukarıdaki
bir fonksiyona
göndermeye
İngilizce'de
ne deniyor
long jump
deniyor
c'de de
long jump
var
yani ben
c'de şunu
yapabilir miyim
f1
f2
işte az önceki
hikaye tekrar
etmeyeyim
f19'dan
programın
akışını
f1'e
çekebilir miyim
evet ya da
hayır deyin
arkadaşlar c'de yapılmıyorsa
c++'da hiç yapılmaz zaten
değil mi
şaka bir yana
çekebilirim tabi
ama bu neyle yapılıyor
standart pütüphanenin
fonksiyonlarıyla
bu fonksiyonları
hatırlıyor musunuz
set jmp
long jmp
fonksiyonlarıyla
yapıyorsunuz bunu
evet
özetle çağrı
vtable ile alakası var mı
hayır
bu konunun
vtable ile uzaktan
yakından bir alakası yok
o zaman
ara vermeden
şöyle bir toparlayalım
biraz daha konuşacağız
geleneksel hata işleme
a
zorlayıcı değil
gerek
erno olsun
gerek geri dönüş
değeri olsun
erno'ya bakmam
geri dönüş
değerini
diskart ederim
o konuda
hiçbir yaptırım
yok
hata işleyen kodla
iş gören kod
iç içe geçmiş
durumda
programın akışı
bir hata olması
durumunda
hatayı
tespit eden
koddan
hatayı işleyen
koda doğrudan
yönlendirilmiyor
herkes
kendisini
çağırana
hata durumunu
bildiriyor
ya da
bildirebiliyor
ama şimdi
bunun dışında
başka
İngilizce
minor
diyebileceğim
nedenler de var
bunlardan da
biraz bahsedelim
şimdi geri dönüş
diyelim
arkadaşlar
peki
soru
diyelim ki
tek yol
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeriyle
hatayı
yönetmek
olsa
konstruktör
ne yapacak
arkadaşlar
invariantları
sınıfın
invariantlarından
bahsettik ya
yani sınıf
nesnesinin
valid state
olmasını
sağlayan
başlangıçta
sınıfın
konstruktör
ya da
geri dönüş
değeri var mı
yok
peki
konstruktör
işini yapıp
yapamadığını
nasıl anlayacak
bu bir
geri dönüş
değeri yok
necati
alt parametre
kullanırım
ama bir de
şöyle problem
var
ya bu
tamamen
akla
aykırı
ben bir sınıf
nesnesi oluşturmaya
çalışıyorum
fighter
ev
konstruktör
çalıştı
fakat
konstruktör
fighter
nesnesinin
iyi varyatlarını
oluşturamadı
o ya da
bu nedenden
e şimdi
exception
and link
dediğimiz
mekanizma
olmasaydı
ki
maalesef
kullanılmayan
yerlerde
bunu bile
yapıyoruz
o zaman
pek yapabileceğimiz
şey
bunu bir
şekilde
bu nesnenin
kullanılmaz
durumda
olduğunu
bildirecek
bir mekanizma
oluşturmamız
gerekir
bu tam bir
felaket
mesela
programın
akışı
buraya
gelecek
ve biz
diyelim ki
sınıfın
valid
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapacağız
valid
true
döndürürse
ev kullanılabilir
bir durumda
valid state
de
arkadaşlar
bazı sınıfların
gerçekten
valid fonksiyonu var
mesela
stud future
sınıfının
valid fonksiyonu var
ama
burada
bu
işin içinden
çıkılmaz bir
hale getirir
işte böyle
nesnelere
yani
constructor çalışmış
exception
ending de yok
sistemde
ya da bir
nedenden
kullanılamıyor
ortada bir
nesne var
ama
nesne mi
değil mi
işte
invariantları
oluşturulmadığı için
kullanılmamış durumda
olan
invalid state
de olan
kullanılmaması
gereken
nesneler için
kullanılan bir
terim dahi var
duydunuz mu
bilmiyorum
zombie object
diyorlar
arkadaşlar
zombie'nin
ne olduğunu
siz benden
daha iyi
biliyorsunuz
niye senden
daha iyi
bilelim
yani işte
zombie filmlerini
seyredenler
seyreden
ben değilim
diyormuş
sanki sizin
seyrettiğiniz
karantı altın
demiş
anlıyorsunuz
değil mi
yani
constructor
zaten
başlı başına
geri dönüş
değeri kavramı
olmadığı için
geri dönüş
değeri
mekanizmasıyla
hatayı
bildirecek
bir
fonksiyon
değil
bu bir
bunu bir yere
koyalım
arkadaşlar
operator
overloading
arkadaşlar
x
string
s1
artı
string
s2
bu
toplama işlemi
yapılamadı
ne olacak
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
string
geri dönüş
değerinin
özel bir değeri
falan olma
ihtimali de yok
kaldı ki
nasıl kontrol edeceğim
bu başka
daha büyük
bir ifadenin
bir bileşeni
olabilir
yani
sadece
operator overloading
operator
fonksiyonları
ve
constructor
geri dönüş
değeriyle
iletmenin
yeterli
olmadığını
ya da
global
error
değişkeniyle
kontrolün
yeterli
olmadığını
gösterecek
bence
kanıt
operator
fonksiyonları
ve
constructor
ama
başka problemler
de var
mesela
ilk döndüren
bir fonksiyonun
işini
yapamadığını
geri dönüş
değeriyle
nasıl
belirleyeceksiniz
eğer
örneğin
bu fonksiyonun
döndürmesi
gereken
değer
pozitif
bir değerse
negatif
olma ihtimali
yoksa
negatif
bir değeri
hata
kodu
yapabilirsiniz
ama
negatif
değer
doğal
bir
değerse
hiçbir
özel
değer
yoksa
nasıl
yapacaksınız
mecbur
bu durumda
ya
global
hata
değişkenini
set edecek
ya da
out
parametre
kullanacak
yani
şöyle
olduğunu
düşünün
int
yıldız
p
error
yani
gideceksiniz
bir
int
nesne
adres
gideceksiniz
hata
olması
durumunda
yapacak
ya da
fonksiyon
iki değer
döndürecek
mesela
bu da
standart
kütüphanede
bazı
yerlerde
var
yani
aslında
iki değeri
bir arada
paketleyen
c'de de
bu kullanılıyor
değil mi
birçok yerde
bazı
kütüphanelerde
siz
bir tane
structure'unuz
olsa
struct
result
şimdi
structure'ınızın
iki tane
elemanı
olsa
int
red
y
basitleştirmiş
olarak
gösteriyorum
int
efendim
flag
fonksiyon
int döndürmek
yerine
result
döndürse
result'un da
biz flag'ine
baksak
flag'den
error olup
olmadığını
anlasak
değil mi
birçok yol var
ama doğal bir yol
yok
out parametre
olabilir
bir
stood
pair
döndürmek
olabilir
gibi
yani bazı
fonksiyon
mesela bakın
int
tipik örnek
atui
standart
si kütüphanesinin
atui
fonksiyonunu
düşünün
atui
şöyle bir
parametrik yapıda
si'de
int döndürüyor
parametresi
constar
yıldız
ve bu fonksiyona
gelen yazdaki
tam sayıyı
döndürüyor
ya bu yazı
geçerli değilse
o zaman
atui
sıfırı
döndürüyor
ama
ama ya yazı
yazıdaki
sayı sıfırsa
yani sayının
kendisi sıfırsa
yine sıfır
döndürüyor
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
yani bazı
fonksiyonların da
sıkıntısı
hadi error
koduna
razıyız
ama
mantıklı bir
error kodu
yok
öyle değil mi
evet
peki
şimdi
geleneksel hata
işleme
ne diyelim
araçlarının
dezavantajlarından
bahsettik
ama bunları da
mutlak
kötü yapmayalım
arkadaşlar
bunlarda da
yine
iyi bir şekilde
mümkün olduğu kadar
iyi şekilde
kullanmamız
gereken
ve standart
C++
kütüphanesinin de
hata
durumunda
işini yapaması
bazen
kullandığı yol bu
yani her zaman
exception and link
araçları
kullanılıyor
demek istemiyorum
buraya kadar
eğer bir sorunuz
yoksa
giriş kısmını
başarılı olarak
tamamladığımızı
düşünüyorum
geleneksel hata
işlenmenin
dezavantajlarından
bahsettik
duruma göre
dezavantaj kabul edilebilecek
görüntülerinden
bahsettik
şimdi
ara vereceğim
aradan sonra
nedir bu
exception and link
nasıl faydalar
sağlıyor
burada
getirdiği
modernite ne
bunlardan
bahsedeceğiz
saat
21.08
arkadaşlar
21.25
de devam edeceğiz
evet
aldığımız yerden
devam ediyoruz
hocam sorabilir miyim
şu an
hocam şu yukarıdaki
şey
call chain
lirin çağrılmasında
exception and link
sırasında
burada asıl
exception and link
yapan üst basamaklardaki
fonksiyonlar
olduğunu söylemiştiniz de
ben bir yeri kaçırdım
diye netleştirmek
amacıyla
şimdi burada
fonksiyon için
yazdığımız
hemen bir yanlış
anlamı olmasın
tamam
öyle olmak zorunda
değil
ama öyle
olabilir dedim
yani
burada
f19'da
oluşan
hataya
müdahale
edecek
kod
doğrudan
f19'un
örneğin geri dönüş
değeriyle
hatayı bildirdiği
f18
olmak zorunda
değil
birçok durumda
call chain'deki
daha yukarıdaki
fonksiyonlardan biri
hataya müdahale ediyor
tamamdır
şimdi daha yukarıdaki
fonksiyonlardan birinin
hataya ilave ettiğini
hani resolve
edebilmesi için
sonuçta
call chain'de
mesela f18'den
f17'ye
en yukarıdaki
basamağa geldiğinde
o kısım resolve
ediyorsa
öyle anlıyor
burada
hani o devrim
niteliğinde
dediğiniz
direkt
f19'daki
exception'ın
en üst basamaklardaki
fonksiyonda
resolve edildiğini
hani aradaki
basamakları
ignorlayıp da
orada
resolve edildiğini
runtime'da nasıl oluyor
kızım orayı
sormak istemiştim
bilmiyorum belki bir yerimi
kaçırdım ama
hayır hiçbir yeri
kaçırmadınız
onu daha anlatmadım
zaten konu
büyük ölçüde
onunla ilgili
tamam o zaman
teşekkür ederim
peki
şimdi
exception handling'in
ne olduğundan
bahsedeceğiz
errorlerin ne olduğundan
bahsettik
runtime errorleri
gelelim
exception handling'in
nasıl
kullanıldığına
C++ dilinde
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
iki
üç konuyu
birbirinden
ayırmak gerekiyor
biri her zaman
olduğu gibi
syntax
yani İngilizce
ifadesiyle
syntax
Türkçe'mizdeki
daha güzel
terimiyle
söz dizim
yani bunlar
açları ne
buradaki
kurallar ne
kuralları
doğru olarak
öğrenmezsek
zaten bir şey
yapmamız
mümkün değil
ama ondan sonra
nasıl
sorusunun
cevabı
ne yapmalıyız
nasıl
yapmalıyız
bunlar
üretimde
nasıl karşımıza
çıkacak
biz önce
syntax tarafından
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
başta da
söyledim
bu tarz
programlama
dillerinin
yani
exception handling
araç setine
sahip
dillerin
exception handling'e
ilişkin
araç seti
birbiriyle
tamamen
aynı olmasa da
mesela
C++'daki
exception handling
lejjava'daki
birbiriyle
aynı değil
ama tabi
çok benzer
öğelere sahip
C++
dilinde
arkadaşlar
3 tane
anahtar sözcükle
oluşturulan
kod birimleri
var
bunlardan
bir tanesi
try
keyword'ü
ve bu
keyword ile
bir blok
oluşturuyoruz
oluşturulan
bloğa
try
block
diyoruz
hatayı
tespit eden
kodun
daha üst
katmanlardaki
koda
hata
kodları
durumundan
haberdar
etmesi için
bir statement
kullanması
gerekiyor
bu statement
throw
keyword ile
oluşturulan
bir
statement
olduğu için
bunu
throw
statement
deniyor
try
block
dediğimiz
blok
aslında
semantik
olarak
şu anlama
geliyor
birazdan
tabii ki
detaylı
göreceğiz
bu blok
içinde
runtime'da
çalışan
kodlardan
biri
bir
exception
gönderirse
ben
buradaki
kodla
bu
exception'a
müdahale
etmek
istiyorum
anlamında
ama
gerçekte
exception'ı
handle
eden
yani
exception'a
müdahale
eden
kodu
oluşturmak
için
patch
anahtar
sözcüğüyle
oluşturulan
blok
ya da
blokları
kullanıyoruz
yani
üç tane
araç
setimizde
önemli
araç
var
biri
throw
keyword'üyle
oluşturulan
throw
statement
diğeri
hata
gönderilmesi
durumunda
hataya
müdahale
edeceğimizi
belirleyen
hatanın
oluşacağı
runtime'a ilişkin
kod aralığını
belirleyen
try
block
bir de
hataya
müdahale
dden
arkadaşlar
catch
block'ları
ya da
block'u
üç tane
temel
öemiz var
bunları
yavaş yavaş
arkadaşlar
göreceğiz
evet
şimdi burada
herkesin
kullandığı
terim
exception'ı
throw etmek
yani
İngilizce
kullanılan
fiil
to
throw
an exception
ne demek bu
önce buradan
başlayalım
yani
sentax'dan önce
exception'ı
throw etmek
ne demek
türçeye
fırlatmak
bana biraz
kaba geliyor ama
hata fırlatma
diyorlar
ben
fırlatmak yerine
gönderme
terimini
kullanıyorum
ve exception
göndermeyi
biraz daha
anlaştır
kılmak için
çoğunlukla
türçede
hata
nesnesi
gönderme
terimini
kullanıyorum
ne demek
to throw
an exception
ben aslında
şöyle bir
analoji
taraftarıyım
her analoji
gibi
%100
orijinaline
sadık
olmak zorunda
değil
ama orijinaline
çağrıştıracak
algılamaya
yardımcı olacak
bir
analoji
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon
işini
yapamadığı
zaman
bir nesne
oluşturuyor
bunu bir
taş gibi
düşünün
ve taşı
yukarıya
doğru fırlatıyor
adeta diyor ki
ey beni çağıran
beni çağıranı
çağıran
çağıranı
yani
kol çeyindeki
daha yukarıdaki
fonksiyonlar
ben işimi
yapamadım
işimi
yapamadığım
bilgisini
içeren
bir nesne
oluşturdum
ve bu
nesneyi
kol çeyinde
yukarı
gönderiyorum
yukarıdaki
kol çeyindeki
fonksiyonlardan
hanginiz
bu hataya
müdahale
etmek istiyorsanız
gönderdiğim
hata
nesnesini
yakalayacaksınız
arkadaşlar
ve bu
hata nesnesini
yakalayarak
ondan
bilgileri
edineceksiniz
ve müdahalenizi
yapacaksınız
o yüzden
burada
hatayı
yakalamak
anlamında
İngilizce'de
kullanılan
fiil
to catch
an
exception
dolayısıyla
kol çeyindeki
bir fonksiyon
error durumuna
düştüğü zaman
eröre
işaret eden
bir hata
nesnesi
oluşturuyor
bu
çok büyük
çoğunlukla
bir sınıf
nesnesi
ama olmak
zorunda
değil
sentaks
açısından
hatta
yine
çoğunlukla
polimorfik
bir sınıf
nesnesi
bu sınıf
yukarıdaki
kodlara
gönderiliyor
yukarıdaki
kodlardan
içinde
try
bloğu olan
kodlardan
biri
bu hatayı
yakalıyor
ya da
yakalamaya
çalışıyor
hatayı
yakalarsa
programın
akışı
exception'ı
throw eden
koddan
exception'ı
catch eden
koda
oradaki
ilgili
catch
bloğuna
çekiliyor
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
görselleştirelim
bir
throw
statement'a
ihtiyacımız var
mesela
foo isimli
bir fonksiyon
olsun
foo fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışmasının
belirli bir
aşamasında
foo fonksiyonu
işini
yapamadığını
gösterecek
bir
exception
throw
etsin
statement'ın
genel
sentaksı
şöyle
throw
expression
denleyicimiz
throw
statement
karşılığı
bir
nesne
oluşturuyor
yukarıdaki
kodlara
gönderilecek
işte bu
nesneye
exception
object
diyoruz
arkadaşlar
burada
özellikle
yanlış
oluşturulan
modellerden
biri
throw
statement'taki
nesnenin
kendisi
gönderilmiyor
yukarı
zaten gönderilse
saçma olur
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesne
zaten
hayatı bitiyor
değil mi
fonksiyondan
çıkışta
yani
örneğin
burada şöyle
bir nesne
olsaydı
int x
eşittir
throw
x
burada
gönderilen
x nesnesinin
kendisi
değil
throw
ifadesi
her zaman
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
oluşturucu
hata
nesnesini
initialize
etmekle
kullanılıyor
yani
kafanızda
şöyle bir
kodu
kurgulayın
derleyici
aslında
kendisi
bir nesne
oluşturacak
tabi o nesnenin
türü
buradaki
ifadenin
türü
int
exception
objekt
bu derleyicinin
hayatını
kontrol ettiği
bir nesne
bu nesne
değerini
throw
expression'dan
yani
throw
anahtar
sözcüğünü
izleyen
ifadeden
alacak
ve yukarıdaki
katmanlara
gönderilen
nesne
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
nesne
olacak
burayı
anlamamız
çok
önemli
bakın
tekrar
söylüyorum
örneğin
my class
diye bir
sınıf
olsaydı
ben burada
otomatik
ömürlü
my class
nesnesi
oluştursaydım
ve
throw statement'ta
bu nesneyi
kullansaydım
yukarı
gönderilen
nesne
m nesnesi
mi
hayır
yukarı
gönderilen
nesne
bu nesne
değil
sadece
derleyicinin
oluşturacağı
exception
objekt
initialize
etmek için
kullanılacak
arkadaşlar
önce
şuradan
başlayalım
forcing
bir mekanizma
olduğunu
söylemiştik
eğer
gönderilen
hata
nesnesi
daha üst katmanlardan
birinde
yakalanmaz ise
önce bu duruma
bir isim verelim
bu duruma
yakalanmayan
yakalanamayan
hata nesnesi
anlamında
uncode
exception
deniyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
uncode
exception
durumunda
standart
kütüphanenin
bir standart
fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
bu fonksiyonun
ismi
stut
terminate
fonksiyonu
programı
sonlandıran
bir fonksiyon
yani programımızın
prosesimizin
azraili
terminate
çağrılması
demek
programın
sonlandırılması
demek
bu da şu
anlama geliyor
eğer gönderilen
bir hata
nesnesi
bilerek
ya da
bilmeden
yakalanmaz
ise
nasıl yakalanacağını
konuşacağız
stut terminate
çağrılıyor
çağrılması
programın
sonlandırılması
demek
ama
burada
bir
customization
pointimiz de
var
ne demek
customization
point
normalde
stut terminate
fonksiyonunun
bir default
davranışı
var
bu
default
davranış
standart
kütüphanenin
c'den gelen
abort
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
abort
fonksiyonu
biliyorsunuz
hiçbir önlem
almadan
programı
anında
sonlandıran
fonksiyon
exit
ile abort
karıştırmayın
exit
normal
termination
fonksiyonu
stut abort
abnormal
termination
fonksiyonu
yani o zaman
biz hiçbir
kastimizasyon
noktasından
istifade
etmemişsek
terminate
çağrılması
demek
abortun
çağrılması
demek
arkadaşlar
yine bunu
bir gösterelim
mesela
diyelim ki
gerçekten
bizim
u isimli
fonksiyonumuz
olsun
bu fonksiyonu
hata durumunu
belirlemek
için
bir
throw
statement'a
sahip
olsun
tabi normalde
bu bir if
deyiminin
tipik olarak
doğru kısmında
olacak
necati
throw
ifadesi
olarak
böyle
intürden
her türden
ifade
kullanabiliriz
boyuttür
haric
ama
tabi bu
üretimde
böyle bir
throw
statement
olacağı
anlamına
gelmiyor
şimdi konumuz
throw
ifadesinin
türüyle
ilgili
değil
uncode
exception'la
ilgili
mesela
main
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
u fonksiyonunu
çağırsa
buraya dikkat
önce şunu
söylemekle
başlayalım
mesela
bakınız
burada bir
statement
olsaydı
cout
iostream'i
dahil
edelim
throw
cold
burada
yine
bazı
statement'lar
olsaydı
who
is
still
running
exception
gönderilmesiyle
bir kere
programın
akışı
fonksiyondan
çıkacak
yani
hiçbir şekilde
şimdi
buradaki
18.
satırdaki
deyimin
yürütülme
ihtimali var
mı
hayır
ya bu
exception
yakalanacak
programın akışı
exception'ı gönderen
koddan
exception'ı yakalayan
yani handle
edecek koda
yönlendirilecek
ya da bu
exception
yakalanamayacak
uncode
exception
durumu
oluşacak
ve uncode
exception
olması
durumunda
standart
kütüphanenin
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
terminate
fonksiyonunda
default
davranışı
stut
abortu
çağırmak
o zaman
şimdi abort
çağrılacak
diyebilir miyiz
özellikle
debug moduna
alıyorum ki
daha iyi
gözleyelim
arkadaşlar bakın
ekranda gördüğümüz
son yazı
full kolt
yazısı
exception
gönderildi
gönderildiği
için
ve exception
yakalanamadığı
için
stut
terminate
çağrıldı
stut
terminate'in
çağrılmasıyla
stut
terminate'e
abortu
çağırdı
abort da
programı
sonlandırdı
ama
programın
abortla
sonlandırıldığını
görüyoruz
abortun
özelliği bu
şimdi
arkadaşlar
dikkat
ama
terminate'in
default
davranışını
değiştirme
şansına
sahibiz
terminate'in
default
davranışını
değiştirmek
için
ismi
set
terminate
olan
bir fonksiyonumuz
var
arkadaşlar
burası
biraz
temel düzeyde
function
pointers
konusunu da
bilmenizi
gerektiriyor
ama
şöyle biraz
anlatalım
stut
terminate'in
nasıl bir
fonksiyon olduğunu
göstermek için
arkadaşlar
terminate
exception
başlık dosyasına
bildirilen bir
fonksiyon
yani ben
şimdi
exception
başlık dosyasını
dahil etmedim
ama
dahil ettiğim dosyalar
exception'i
dahil ediyor
aslında
yine
exception
başlık
dosyasında
bir
type
alias var
bu
type
alias
bir
function
pointer'a
ilişkin
pipedef
ya da
using
yazayım
daha kolay
olsun diye
using
arkadaşlar
void
using
terminate
handler
eşittir
void
yıldız
parametresi
yok
ister
bu
bildirimi
böyle
yapmış
olayım
söyleyin
bakalım
type
def
anahtar
sözcüğüyle
bu
bildirimi
yapsaydık
c bilenler
pipedef
void
yıldız
terminate
handler
arkadaşlar
böyle
yapacak
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
sonuçta
biz
exception
başlık
dosyasını
include
ettiğimizde
bu type
alias
declaration'ı
da
kodumuza
eklemiş
oluyoruz
şimdi
function
pointers
konusunda
hepinizin
bildiğini
varsayarak
bir soralım
burada
terminate
handler
nasıl bir
türün
eş ismi
geri dönüş
değeri
olmayan
parametresi
bir
fonksiyon
adresi
türü
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
geri dönüş
değeri
olmayan
parametresi
bir
efendim
fonksiyon
adresi
türü
yani
onun
eş
ismi
arkadaşlar
ama
yine
exception
başlık
dosyası
bize
set
terminate
isimli
bir
fonksiyon
veriyor
burası
önemli
set
terminate
fonksiyonu
şöyle
bir
fonksiyon
buraya
dikkat
set
terminate
parametresi
handler
yani
benden
bir
function
pointer
istiyor
ve
geri dönüş
değeri
de
yine
terminate
handler
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
bu
ne
demek
set
terminate
adı
üstünde
terminate
davranışını
set eden
fonksiyon
eğer
siz
terminate
abortu
çağırması
yerine
sizin
belirlediğiniz
bir
fonksiyonu
çağırmasını
isterseniz
set
terminate
fonksiyonunuzun
adresini
geçmelisiniz
necati
örnek
verebilir misin
tabi
örneğin
o
parametrek
yapıda
yani
geri dönüş
değeri
olmayan
parametresi
my
terminate
isimli
bir
fonksiyon
olsun
bu
fonksiyonun
çağrıldığını
göstermek
için
bir yazı
yazdıralım
my
terminate
called
c++
dilinin
kurallarına
göre
semantik
kurallarına
göre
bu fonksiyonun
return etmemesi
gerekiyor
bu fonksiyonu
diyelim ki
o ya da
bu nedenle
standart
exit
fonksiyonunu
çağırsın
sadece
burada bir
kastimizasyon
noktası
olduğunu
göstermek
istiyorum
şimdi
bakın
eğer ben
main fonksiyonunun
örneğin başında
sput
terminate'i
çağırırsam
set terminate'e
my terminate
fonksiyonunun
adresine
argümanı
olarak
geçersem
böylece
terminate
çağrıldığımda
artık
default
davranışını
değiştirmiş
oluyorum
bunun da
nasıl
yapılan
c'de
anlatıyorum
function
pointers
fonosunda
belki o kursa
katılan
arkadaşlarımı
hatırlayacaklar
şimdi
yine
exception
yakalanmayacak
ama
terminate'in
default
davranışını
değiştirdiğimiz
için
yine
terminate
çağırılacak
bunu değiştirme
şansımız yok
ama
terminate
abortu
çağırmak
yerine
bizim
custom
fonksiyonumuz
my terminate'i
çağıracak
set terminate'in
geri dönüş
değeri de
function
pointer
yani
siz
set terminate'i
bu da zaten
çok
konvensyonel
bir yapı
idiomatik
yeni adresi
set ediyor
eskisini
get ediyor
yani böyle
fonksiyonlara
ben get set diyorum
hem set işlemi
yapıyor
hem get işlemi
yani ben
örneğin
set terminate
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığım
noktada
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
bir değişkende
saklarsam
set terminate
çağrılmadan
önce
set terminate
hangi
terminate
hangi fonksiyonu
çağırıyorsa
arkadaşlar
yani terminate
enter olarak
ne kullanılıyorsa
o
onun
nesini
verecek
arkadaşlar
adresini
verecek
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
peki
yani
terminate'in
default davranışını
özelleştirebiliyoruz
bunu şimdilik
bir kenara
ayıralım
ama şimdilik
bu bizim için
bir detay
seviyesinde
uncode exception
olması durumunda
terminate
çağrılıyor
abortu
çağırıyor
ya da
set terminate'le
bir fonksiyon
set edilmişse
onu çağırıyor
ama sonuçta
bu fonksiyonlar
programı
sonlandıran
fonksiyonlar
bu arada
benim
set ettiğim
fonksiyon
da
programı
sonlandırmak
zorunda
şöyle bir
bu arada arkadaşlar
set terminate
daha önce de
vardı
yani
modern c++'a
gelen bir fonksiyon
değil
ama modern c++'da
bir de
get terminate
eklendi
yani
doğrudan
get terminate
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
get terminate
fonksiyonunun
parametresi yok
geri dönüşleri
terminate
enders
en son
set edilmiş
terminate
ender hangisi ise
onun
adresini
döndürüyor
yani
burada
üç tane
fonksiyonumuz var
biri
terminate
sonlandırmayı
yapan fonksiyon
onun
davranışını
değiştiren
set terminate
fonksiyonu
ve
bir de
get terminate
fonksiyonu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
eğer
herhangi bir
terminate
fonksiyonu
set edilmemişse
o zaman da
null pointer
döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
get terminate
fonksiyonu
peki
şimdi
burayı
geçelim
buraya daha sonra
geri döneceğiz
biraz daha ayrıntıya
girmek için
hata nesnesinin
yakalanmaması
durumunda
uncode
exception
durumunda
zorlayıcı
forcing
mekanizma
programın
sonlandırılması
hiçbir
garanti
vermeden
programın
sonlandırılması
biz bunu
kasıtlı olarak
bazen
istiyoruz
yani özellikle
sonlandırılsın
arkadaşlar
ama
bazen
çoğu zaman
bu bizim
istemediğimiz
bir durum
ki nedenle
çoğunlukla
istemediğimiz
bir durum
eğer
bilerek
isteyerek
terminate'in
çağrılmasını
sağlamamışsak
iki nedenden
birincisi
artık
program
sonlandığına
göre
programın
işini
yapma
şansı
yok
yani bitmiş
ne yapacak
işini
öyle değil mi
ikincisi
yakalanamayan
hata nesnesi
durumunda
arkadaşlar
birdenbire
program
sonlanıyor
yani
tipik olarak
biz
gerçekten
programı
mesela
şöyle de olabilir
artık o hatanın
handle edilecek
bir yanı
kalmamıştır
biz hatayı
yakalarız
ama
kontrollü
bir şekilde
kaynakların
geri verileceği
ilgili yerlere
haber verilecek
şekilde
belki bir
loglama yapılacak
şekilde
programı
sonlandırmamız
gerekiyor
tipik olarak
bu arada
şundan da bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
exception handling
iki ayrı
biçimde kullanılıyor
birincisi
İngilizcesiyle
resemptive
bu çoğunluk
senaryosu
yani
buradaki
resemptive
ne demek
İngilizce
resume
fiilinin
isim hali
yani
devam ettirmeye
yönelik
yani
hatadır
olur
istisnai
bir durum
hata
işini
yapamadı
ama
biz
çaresine
bakıyoruz
ve programın
çalışmasını
devam
ettiriyoruz
mesela
kullanıcı
açısından
bakarsanız
kullandığımız
programlarda
olmuyor mu
ekranda
mavi bir
pencere
çıkıyor
işte şu anda
bu işlemi
gerçekleştiremiyoruz
devam etmek için
bir tuşa basın
vesaire
yazıyor
program çalışmaya
devam ediyor
arkadaşlar
yalnız
programın
çalışmaya
devam etmesi
yani
resemptive
bir metodoloji
kullanıyorsak
programın
gerçekten
çalışmaya
sağlıklı
bir şekilde
İngilizcesiyle
yine
valid state
devam etmesi
gerekiyor
mesela şu
kabul edilebilir
bir durum mu
bunların hepsini
ayrıca konuşacağız
exception'i gönderdi
bir kod
bir kod da
yakaladı
program çalışmaya
devam ediyor
exception sözde
handle edildi
ama
resource leak
oluşmuş
kaynaklar
sızdırılmış
ya da program
geçerli bir state
değil
geçerli bir durumda
olmayan programın
çalışması
çalışmamasına göre
çok daha kötü
öyle değil mi
yani resemptive
yol izliyorsak
programın
bir valid state
de kalması
çalışmaya
o şekilde
devam etmesini
tipik olarak
garanti altında
alıyoruz
ileride bu garantiye
basic garanti
dendiğini
öğreneceğiz
ikinci yol
terminatif olabilir
yani
program
bir hataya
düştüğünde
artık o hata
İngilizcesiyle
bir
recovery
yapılabilecek
bir durum
olmayabilir
ne yapayım
yani artık
programın
işletim sistemi
düzeyinde
bir hata var
arkadaşlar
ne yapayım
programın
çalışmasından
devam etmesi
imkanı yok
burada da artık
birinci amaç
programı
gerekli yerlere
haber vererek
lognamalar
vesaire
yaparak
artık programın
çalıştığı
domenle ilgili
sağlıklı bir
şekilde
sonlandırmak
hangisi
daha yaygın
şimdi burada
şöyle istatistiksel
olarak bakarsak
resemptive
yaklaşım mı
daha çok
yani sıklık
olarak
terminatif mi
cevap
resemptive
tabii ki
evet
yani
amacımız
çoğu zaman
tamam hata oldu
beklenmeyen bir durum
oluştu
ve
biz yine de
programın
hizmet vermeye
devam etmesini
istiyoruz
arkadaşlar
zaten
öyle programlar
var ki
terminatif olması da
çok büyük bir risk
değil mi
düşünsenize
bankanın kredi kartı
işlemlerini yöneten
hava yollarının
bagaj sistemini yöneten
vesaire
programlar
oh
exception oldu
program sonlansın
oradaki kayıp
milyonlarca doları
bulabilir
burayı anladık mı
resemptive ya da
terminatif
olabilir
sonuçta
bizim
tipik olarak
yapmamız gereken
o tipik senaryodan
bahsedeceğim
exception'i
yakalamak
yakaladığımızda
a
program
in a valid state
geçerli bir durumda
çalışmaya devam
edecek
b
gerekli önlemler
alınarak
bir kayıp
olmadan
mümkünse
ya da
minimal kayıpla
bir loklama
vesaire
yapılarak
program
sonlanacak
ama bunun için
exception'i
yakalamamız
gerekiyor
şimdi
exception'i
nasıl yakalayacağız
gelelim oraya
arkadaşlar
try anahtar
sözcüğüyle
bir blok
oluşturuyoruz
oluşturduğumuz
bu bloğa
try block
deniyor
şu anlama
geliyor
bu blok
içinde
çalışan
kodlardan
biri
exception
trove
ederse
ben bu
blok
bu kodu
yazan
programcı
olarak
o hatayı
burada
yakalama
niyetindeyim
burada
yalnız
bir şeyi
çok iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
try block
statik olarak
bakarsa
bir blok
sadece
beni izleyin
try block
bir blok
olması ne
demek
örneğin
burada
ben bir değişken
tanımlasam
bu bir isim
identifier
değil mi
bu ismin
bir skopu
var
değil mi
örneğin
bu ismi
burada
kullanabilir
miyim
evet
ya da
hayır
deyin
cevap
hayır
yani
try block
gerçekten de
bir blok
skopu
oluşturuyor
mesela yeni
başlayanların
başlangıçta
tabii çok
çok
başlangıçta
en tipik
hatalarından
biri
try
bloku içinde
bir isim
oluşturup
tipik olarak
bir değişken
tanımlayıp
try blokunun
dışında
o değişkeni
ismiyle
kullanmak
istemeleri
ama
skopunun
dışında
kullanmış
oluyoruz
yani bu
açıdan
baktığımızda
try
gerçekten de
bir
skop
oluşturuyor
ama
ben bu
blok içinde
gönderilen
exception'ı
yakalamaya
niyetliyim
derken
kastedilen
pro
statement'ın
kendisinin
bu blok
içinde
olması
değil
bu da
olabilir
ama
mesela
diyelim ki
ben burada
var fonksiyonunu
çağırmış
olsam
var fonksiyonu
bas fonksiyonunu
çağırmış
olsa
bas fonksiyonu
full fonksiyonunu
çağırmış
olsa
ve
full fonksiyonu
exception
prove
etse
halen
ben
gönderilen
exception'ı
yakalama
şansına
sahip
miyim
evet
anlaşıldı
değil mi
try
blue
sonuçta
runtime'da
burada
çalışacak
kodları
katlediyor
burada
isterse
20 derinlikle
bir
call chain
olsun
call
chain'in
en dibindeki
fonksiyon
exception
gönderse
ben bu
exception'ı
yakalamaya
adayım
neden
dediğimi
birazdan
anlayacaksınız
şimdi
try
blue
kısa
da
olsa
göstermiş
olduk
arkadaşlar
try
blue
ilk başına
olamıyor
yani örneğin
böyle bir
try
blue
oluştursam
sentaps
hatası
try
blue
ondan
sonra
en az
bir tane
catch
blue
olmak
zorunda
ama
birden fazla
catch
blue
olabilir
arkadaşlar
catch
blokları
şöyle
oluşturuluyor
catch
key
bird
ve
catch
key
bird
önden sonra
catch
parantezi
ve
catch
parantezinin içinde
parametresi
sanki bir
fonksiyon gibi
ama sakın
fonksiyonla
karıştırmayalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu ne demek
biraz bundan
bahsedelim
bir kere
hemen
şunu söyleyin
catch
de bir blok
derken
örneğin
burada
birazdan
detaylı
anlatacağım
catch
parametresi
olan
değişkenin
ismini
ya da
buradaki
bir
yerel
değişkenin
ismini
bu blok
dışında
başka bir
yerde
kullanabilir
miyim
hayır
nasıl
try
bir blok
ise
bir skop
belirliyorsa
catch
blokları
da
birer
skop
belirliyor
gerek
catch
parametresi
dediğim
değişkenin
ismini
gerek
blok
içinde
tanımladığım
isimleri
sadece
bu blok
içinde
kullanabilirim
arkadaşlar
bu ne
demek
burayı
şimdi
çok iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
önce
sentaksa
bakalım
catch
parametresinin
olmaması
gibi bir
ihtimal
var mı
hayır
sentaksa
aykırı
birden fazla
catch
parametresi
olabilir mi
mesela
örneğin
şöyle bir
ifade
kod
yazabilir
miyim
hayır
bir tane
catch
parametresi
olacak
catch
parametresinin
türü
olacak
sentaks olarak
uygulama
pratiğinden
bahsetmiyorum
catch
parametresi
bir sınıf
türünden
olabilir
primitif
türden
olabilir
oyun tıp
türü
olabilir
lvalue
referansı
olabilir
rvalue
referansı
olabilir
constel
value
referansı
olabilir
yani
eğer
bahsettiğimiz
best
practice
değilse
catch
parametresinin
herhangi bir
türden
olması
konusunda
bir
engel
yok
tıpkı
fonksiyonlarda
olduğu gibi
catch
parametresine
de tıpkı
fonksiyonun
parametre
değişkenlerinde
olduğu gibi
catch
parametresine
isim vermek
zorunda
değilsiniz
ve fonksiyonlarla
ilgili söylediğimi
burada
catch
parametresi
için de
söyleyeceğim
eğer bu
catch
parametresini
bloğunun
içinde
kullanmayacaksanız
değerleyicinizin
a
uyarı
mesajı
vermemesi
için
b
kodu
okuyanın
bilinçli
olarak
bu
değişkenin
kullanılmadığını
anlaması
için
lütfen
fonksiyonlar
için de
aynı
uyarıyı
yapmıştım
catch
parametresine
isim
vermeyin
try
bloğunu
izleyen
birden
fazla
catch
bloğu
olabilir
ama
bu durumda
catch
parametreleri
farklı
türden
olmak
zorunda
örneğin
bu
int
double
arkadaşlar
bu
ne
olsun
çar
olabilir
sakın
bana
şimdi
konuyla
ilgili
derin
bilgiye
sahip
arkadaşlar
ki
mutlaka
var
aramızda
necati
ben hiç
böyle
catch
bloğu
görmedim
demesinler
ben de
görmedim
görme
ihtimalinizde
çok
kuvvetli
değil
ama
özellikle
yazıyorum
önce
sentaks
anlamanız
için
şimdi
gelelim
bunun
anlamına
arkadaşlar
eğer
try
bloğu
içinde
çalışan
kodlardan
biri
bir
exception
throw
ederse
örnekte
olduğu
gibi
gönderilen
exception
nesnesinin
bir
türü
var
değil mi
mesela
şu anda
gönderilen
exception
nesnesinin
türü
ne
alihan
olsan
cevap
int
eğer
try
bloğunu
izleyen
catch
bloklarından
biri
exception
nesnesinin
türüyle
aynı
türden
parametreye
sahipse
programın
akışı
runtime'da
exception
handle
edilmesi
için
bu
bloğun
içine
girecek
yani
örneğin
arkadaşlar
lütfen dikkat
burayı
anlamanız
çok önemli
hata
ingilizce
yazayım
exception
code
arkadaşlar
catch
int
yani
programın
akışının
buraya
girdiğini
göstermek
için
yazıyorum
altına
arkadaşlar
özellikle bu konuda hiç acele etmek gibi bir niyetim yok
benden hızlı anlatmamı istiyorsanız
sizi hayal kırıklığına uğratacağım
çünkü her bir ayrıntı
örneğimde
evet
double
char
bakın şimdi
eğer gönderilen
exception
nesnesinin
türü int ise
tıpkı
breakli bir
switch statement gibi
programın akışı
nereye çekilecek
exception'i yakalayan
bu
catch
bloğuna
bu blok içindeki
kodlar
yürütülecek
eğer burada
eğer burada herhangi bir şekilde
efendim program sonlandırılmamışsa
ya da daha sonra anlatacağımız şekilde bir müdahale söz konusu değilse
exception
handle edilmiş olacak
ve programın akışı
bakın bakın
en son catch bloğundan sonraki kodla
yani try catch bloğlarını izleyen kodla
devam edecek
şimdi
sadece beni izliyorsunuz
bakınız
programı değerliyorum
bu neye bir örnek
hatayı yakalamaya bir örnek
exception
code
catch
int
bir şey daha görmenizi istiyorum
eğer ben
gönderilen hata nesnesinin
kendisini
kullanmak isteseydim
yani sadece
türüyle bir ayrım
yaratmak yerine
o nesnenin
değerini de
kullanmak isteseydim
tıpkı fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeni gibi
arkadaşlar
bu nesnenin
değerini
kullanabilirdim
isim vereyim
aynı ismi
kullanabilirim
şüphesiz ama
daha iyi takip edin diye
farklı isimler vereceğim
b eşittir
e
iman
şark c eşittir
sabırla
izleyiniz
şimdi bakın
gönderilen hata nesnesinin
türü
int
değeri
hata
hata yakalandı
programın akışı
catch
bloğuna çekildi
parametresine
exception
object'in
değeri
kopyalandı
arkadaşlar
ve ben o değeri
bir şekilde
kullandım
ama
artık burada
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
söz ettiğim
eylemlerden
herhangi birini
yapmadığım için
programın akışı
exception'in
handle edilmiş
olması sonucuyla
try
bloğundan
sonraki
kodla
devam etti
neco
peki ben
örneğin
burada
double türden
bir
throw expression
kullansaydım
şimdi de
programın akışı
40.
satırdaki
catch
bloğuna mı
çekilecekti
kesinlikle
evet
bakın
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
peki neco
charterden
olsaydı
bu durumda da
programın
akışı
yine
char
parametreli
catch
bloğuna
çekilecekti
arkadaşlar
deniz
sormuş
ben de
tam onu
söyleyecektim
burada
conversion
yok demeyelim
ama çok
kısıtlı var
mesela
char
parametreli
catch
bloğu
olmasaydı
char
dan
int'e
dönüşüm
var
normalde
hatta bu
integral
promotion
int parametreli
catch bloğu
bu exception'i
yakalayacak
mıydı
cevap
hayır
exception
yakalanmamış
olacaktı
yine
uncode exception
olacaktı
gördük
değil mi
yine
benzer
şekilde
bakınız
gönderilen
hata
nesnesi
float türden
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
double parametreli
catch bloğu
bu hatayı
yakalayacak
mıydı
cevap
hayır
anlaşıldı
değil mi
burada
arkadaşlar
sadece
çok kısıtlı
conversion söz konusu
ama tabi
birçok arkadaşım
tahmin ediyor
burada
kabul etilen
conversion
türemiş sınıftan
tavan sınıfa
olan
dönüşüm
ki
birazdan
odak noktamız
olacak bu
oraya biraz
yolumuz var
bu önce
denizin sorusuna
biraz daha
kapsamlı cevap
vereyim
arkadaşlar bakın
şu
hiçbir dönüşüm
yok
mesela
şu anda
intörden
ama
bunu
unsighting türden
yaptım
normalde
intten
unsighting türüne
dönüşüm var
ama burada
gördüğünüz gibi
exception
yakalanamadı
deniz anlaştık mı
bu konuda
sorunuza cevap
aldınız mı
ama şimdi bakın
ileriye doğru
yolumuzu da
göstermek için
şöyle bir şey yapalım
class base
class
der
public
base
ve gönderilen
hata nesnesi
der türünden
olsun
takip edebiliyor muyuz
gördüğünüz gibi
raw expression
olarak
der sınıfı
türünden
bir
temporary
object
expression
kullandım
ve
bir catch
blue
daha ekleyeyim
bu sefer
catch blue
const
base
ref
olsun
ve
exception
code
catch
base
ref
bu yazı
çıksın
yeter
şimdi bakın
sadece
kabul edilebilir
çok az sayıda
dönüşüm var
dedik ama
bizi ilgilendiren
asıl bu
gönderilen hata
nesnesinin
türü ne
der
er der
bir base mi
evet
bu durumda
arkadaşlar
parametresi
const
base
ref olan
elverdi referans
const
olan
catch
blue
bu hatayı
yakalayacak mı
bakıyoruz
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
blue
called
exception
code
catch
base
ref
yani
polimorifik
olsun ya da
olmasın
çoğunlukla da
polimorifik
olacak
bu
exception
sınıfları
düremiş
sınıf
türünden
gönderilen
hata
nesnesini
avans
sınıf
türünden
bir
catch
parametresi
ile
yakalayabilirsiniz
şimdi
eğer
buraya
kadar sorunuz
yoksa
aslında
olmasın
da
çünkü
konunun
çok
başındayız
muhtemelen
sorduğunuz
soruların
hepsinin
cevabı
bugün
ya da
çarşamba
günü
alınacak
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
exception
göndermeye
geri dönelim
true ifadesiyle
aslında
gönderilen
hata
nesnesiyle
birlikte
biz
yukarıdaki
kodlara
iki farklı
biçimde
bilgi
vermiş
oluyoruz
burayı
çok dikkatli
izleyin
birincisi
doğrudan
true edilen
nesnenin
türü
arkadaşlar
atipik
uygulamalara
bakmazsanız
onlar çok
seyrek
hatta çok
çok seyrek
karşınıza
çıkar
tipik olarak
true ifadeleri
bu iş için
özel olarak
oluşturulmuş
yani
exception
handling'de
kullanmak
amaçlı
oluşturulmuş
sınıflar
türünden
olacak
dolayısıyla
örneğin
mat exception
isimli bir
sınıfım
olsaydı
bu sınıf
zaten
varlık
nedeni
bu sınıfın
exception
handling'de
kullanılacak
olması
ve
eğer
gönderilen
rov edilen
exception
bu türdense
isminin de
ima ettiği
gibi
söz konusu
hatanın
örneğin
matematikle
ilgili olduğu
anlamına
geliyor
yani
biz
birinci bilgiye
neyle
vermiş oluyoruz
gönderilen
hata
nesnesini
zaten
türüyle
vermiş oluyoruz
dolayısıyla
intürden
double
türden
arkadaşlar
exception
göndermek
sentaks
açısından
bir
engel
oluşturmasa da
uygulama
pratiğinde
böyle bir durum
hiç karşınıza
çıkmaz
belki
inum
türlere
bir ihtimal
kullanıldığı
kütüphaneler
var
ama asla
int
double
vesaire
gönderilmez
yani örneklerde
benim de
az önce
yazdığım
örnekte
olduğu gibi
int
türden
double
exception
throw
etmişse
o
sentaksı
anlatmak
içindir
genel yapıyı
anlatmak
içindir
o zaman
zaten kütüphanede
tipik olarak bunu
dokümante edecek
mesela diyecek ki
bu fonksiyon
işini yapamadığı
zaman
mat exception
sınıfı
türünden
bir exception
gönderir
diyecek
zaten bunu
dokümantasyonda
göreceksiniz
dolayısıyla
gönderilen
hata
nesnesinin
türü
hatayla ilgili
bir bilgi
verecek
mesela
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
file error
dosya işlemiyle
ilgili
gönderilen
hatalar için
kullanılan
bir sınıf
olabilir
hatta
file
read error
efendim
dosyadan
okunma
yapılması
durumunda
oluşacak
hatayı
bildirmek
için
kullanılan
bir
tür
olabilir
mesela
divide
by
zero
error
adı üstünde
sıfıra
bölme
durumunda
gönderilecek
bir
hata
nesnesinin
türü
olabilir
yani
türün kendisi
bir kere
bilgi veriyor
ama
sonuçta
gönderilen
hata
nesnesinde
adı üstünde
bir
objekt
bir state'e
de sahip
olabilir
mesela
şöyle bir şey
olabilir mi
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
file
readerer
isimli
bir sınıf
var
dosyadan
okuma
yaptığımız zaman
bir hata
olduğunda
file
readerer
isimli
sınıf
türünden
bir hata
gönderiyor
ben hatayı
burada
exception
anlamında
kullanıyorum
bir exception
gönderiliyor
ve
belki de
bu sınıfın
bir takım
üye fonksiyonları
var olmayacak
iş değil
mesela
isim
suxting
file name
post
efendim
tamamen
piknik bir
örnek
yani
standart
bahaneden
bahsetmiyorum
int
get
line
no
comes
mesela bu sınıfın
dokumentasyonunda
diye olabilir ki
Alihan
Oğuzhan
efendim
file readerer
sınıfının
get
file name
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
size döndürdüğü
string
ya da
const
çağır yılı
string döndürmek
pek akıllıcı
olmayabilir
duruma göre
efendim
hangi
dosyadan
okuma
yapıldığında
hata
oluşmuşsa
o dosyanın
ismi
get line
no
dosyanın
üçüncü
satırından
okuma yapılırken
hata
oluşmuşsa
o satırın
numarası
gibi
burayı
anladık mı
çoğunluk
senaryosu
yani
istatistiksel
olarak
bakarsak
arkadaşlar
çok büyük
çoğunlukla
biz
bilginin
tamamını
bir
türle
iletiyoruz
ama
böyle
türlerin
tipik olarak
bir
yazı
döndüren
fonksiyonu
oluyor
yani
en çok
uygulamalarda
ya türün
kendisini
kullanıyoruz
başka bir
şeyle
ilgilenmiyoruz
önemli olan
o türden
hataya
müdahale
etmek
ama
bazen de
bunu
bir
bizim
ne olduğunu
anlayabileceğimiz
duruma
işaret eden
bir
yazıyla
da
aynı zamanda
elde etmek
istiyoruz
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
en kritik yerlerden
birine gelelim
dedik ya
hata
nesnesinin
türü
hatanın
neyle ilgili
olduğu
konusunda
bize
birinci
elden
bilgi
veriyor
mesela
diyelim ki
out of range
isimli bir
sınıf olsun
işte
bu sınıf
türünden
bir hata
nesnesi
gönderildiğinde
hata
olması
gereken
range'in
dışında
bir değer
söz konusu
olduğu için
gönderilmiş olsun
öylece ben
out of range
gönderildiğinde
hatanın
neyle ilgili
olduğunu
zaten
baştan
biliyor olacağım
ve
çok büyük
çoğunlukla
hatalar
gönderildiği
zaman
ya
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesindeki
exception
tavan
tavan sınıfıyla
başlayan
hiyerarşideki
sınıflar
kullanılıyor
en tipik
karşımıza
çıkacak
senaryolar
bir
arkadaşlar
gönderilen
hata
nesnesinin
buraya dikkat
stud
exception
türünden
olması
stud
exception
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesinin
bir detaylı
inceleyeceğiz
exception
handling
kullanılacak
sınıfların
taban
sınıfı
ve
polimorfik
bir sınıf
dolayısıyla
standart
kütüphane
diyor ki
ben
diyor size
şu
garanti
veriyorum
eğer
diyor
bir
exception
standart
kütüphanenin
bir
fonksiyonu
gönderiyorsa
ya da
standart
kütüphanenin
bir
operatörünün
kullanılması
sonucunda
bu
exception
gönderiliyorsa
mutlaka ve mutlaka
bu exception
ya
stud
exception
türünden
olacak
ya da
yine
stud
exception
türünden
olacak
ama
ne anlamda
is a
relationship
anlamında
yani
kalıtım
yoluyla
public
kalıtım
yoluyla
stud
exception
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
sınıflardan
birinden
olacak
bu da şu
demek
eğer siz
diyelim ki
bir
try
bloğu
oluşturup
burada
standart
kütüphanenin
gönderdiği
hatalardan
hangisi
olursa olsun
onu yakalamak
istiyorsanız
e tabi
bunun garantili
yolu
en tepedeki
avans
sınıf
türünden
catch
parametrenizin
olması
stud
buraya
dikkat
exception
ref
ex
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok
dikkatli
izleyelim
gönderilen
hata
nesneleri
atipik
senaryolar
söz konusu
olmaz ise
her zaman
referans
semantiği
ile yakalanıyor
yani
eğer
catch
parametresi
l
value
referans
türünden
değilse
ortada
hiç olmaz
demiyorum ama
atipik
bir senaryo
vardır
bunların sayısı
çok çok
az
buraya
dikkat
dolayısıyla
exception'ı
handle edecek
kodu
yazacaksınız
%99
yapmanız
gereken
catch
parametresinin
bir
l
value
referansı
olması
yalnız
buraya
dikkat
yine
çok
büyük
çoğunlukla
biz
yakaladığımız
hata
nesnesi
üstünde
bir
set
işlemi
yapmıyoruz
aslında pekala
yapma hakkına
sahibiz
yani örneğin
burada
net exception
sınıfı
türünden
bir referans
olsaydı
pekala
şu da
olabilirdi
değil mi
bu
net exception
sınıfının
set fonksiyonları
olabilirdi
exception
nesnesi
üstünde
mutation
yapmak için
onun örneğin
değerini
değiştirmek
için
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
eğer
böyle bir
durum söz
konusu
değilse
parametreyi
mutlaka ve mutlaka
const
referans
yapın
yani
const
correctness
burada
uymanız
son derece
önemli
yani
const
value
referans
yapmamanızı
makul
kılacak
neredeyse
tek senaryo
ne
exception
nesnesini
üstünde
bir
set işlemi
yapmak
yani örneğin
exception
sınıfının
add
info
diye bir
fonksiyonu
olsaydı
bu fonksiyon
sınıfın
non
const
member
fonksiyonu
olsaydı
burada
sentax
hatası
olurdu
değil mi
arkadaşlar
takip ediyor
musunuz
bir tepki
şöyle
Allah rızası
için
evet
şakır
o zaman
zaten
sentax
hatası
olurdu
bu durumda
parametrenin
const
olmayan
referans
olması
gerekiyor
iki
yine
baştan
söylemiştim
eğer
sadece
exception
yakalamak
niyetindeyseniz
catch
parametresini
bloğu içinde
kullanmayacaksınız
o zaman
zaten
isimlendirme
de yapmayın
arkadaşlar
standart kütüphanenin
exception
yerarşisini
inceleyeceğiz
ama burada
çok önemli
bir fonksiyona
değinelim
sınıfın
exception
sınıfının
ismi
what
olan
ve
const
çar
yıldız
döndüren
bir
virtual
function
var
bu şu
demek
türemiş
sınıflar
bu fonksiyonu
override
ediyorlar
yani
siz
örneğin
exception
sınıfı
türünden
bir
referansla
bu hatayı
yakaladığınız
zaman
referans
semantini
kullanarak
sanal fonksiyon
çağrısı
yapabilirsiniz
değil mi
yani örneğin
burada
ben
x'in
sanal fonksiyonu
olan
what'ı
çağırdığımda
ki bu fonksiyon
const
çar
yıldız
döndürecek
örnekler
vereceğiz
ne devreye
girecek
virtual
dispatch
mekanizması
devreye
girecek
yani
gönderilen
hata
nesnesi
örneğin
stu
exception
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
logic
error
sınıfı
türündense
onun
watt
override
çağrılacak
efendim
yok
gönderilen
hatta
nesnesi
logic
error
sınıfından
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
örneğin
out of range
sınıfı
türündense
onun
watt
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
şimdi
standart
kötü
bahanenin
exception
yararsız
zaten
belirli bir
detay
seviyesinde
inceleyeceğiz
örnekler
vereceğiz
ama
önce bu
virtual dispatch
kısmını
bir görmemiz
anlamamız
gerekiyor
önce işin
semantik
tarafına
bakalım
arkadaşlar
mesela
benim
en tepede
ayrı bir
platformum
olsaydı
standart
kütüphanenin
exception
yararşisi
arkadaşlar
kullanmasaydım
belki
en tepede
exception
base
isimli bir
sınıfım
olacaktı
belki ondan
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
mat
exception
isimli bir
sınıfım
olacaktı
belki ondan
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
divide
by
zero
error
gibi
farklı farklı
sınıflar
olacaktı
bakın bu ne
demek
ben
exception
yakalamaya
aday
kodu yazan
programcı
olarak
şöyle
seçeneklerim
var
eğer
exception
base'den
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilen
herhangi bir
sınıf türünden
exception'i
yakalamak
istersem
parametresi
exception
base olan
kod
catch
bloğunu
kullanacağım
hayır hayır
ben sadece
matematikle
ilgili
exception'ları
yakalamak
istiyorsam
catch
parametresini
math
except
yapacağım
ama ben
exactly
only
sadece
divide by
zero
errori
yakalamak
istiyorsam
arkadaşlar
o zaman
da
catch
parametresini
bu sınıf
türünden
yapacağım
bunların
hepsi
bir arada
da olabilir
ama
yukarıdan
aşağı
doğru
konumlandırmak
gerekiyor
çünkü
control
runtime'da
yukarıdan
aşağı
doğru
yapılıyor
mesela
bir canlı
örnek
verelim
vaktimiz
azaltı
ama
ne yapalım
yapacak
bir şey yok
bakınız
her şeyi
siliyorum
hayatımdan
vektörlük başlık
hadi
vektörlü dediğin
stringi zaten
öğrendik
belirli
seviyede
mesela
ben
string sınıfının
at
isimli
fonksiyonun
aslında
geçersiz
indeks
olması
durumunda
standart
kütüphanenin
out of range
sınıfı
türünden
exception
gönderdiğini
söylemiştim
hatırlıyor musunuz
hatta
köşeli parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
indeksin
geçersiz
olması
durumunda
exception
prove
etmiyor
tanımsız
davranış
oluşturuyor
ama
add
fonksiyonu
out of range
sınıfı
türünden
bir
exception
prove
ediyor
mesela
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyonum
olsaydı
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
bir
stu
string
nesnesi
olsaydı
stu
string
name
efendim
deniz
akkoş
ve burada
exception
true
edecek
bir
ifade
yazsaydım
name
auto
c
eşittir
name
at
arkadaşlar
stu
size
t
idx
bu
lojik bir yapı
aramayın
idx
şimdi
bu fonksiyon
exception
true
edecek
eğer
indeks
geçerli bir
değil ise
mesela
bakınız
arkadaşlar
full
fonksiyonuna
değerini
argüman olarak
geçiyorum
exception
gönderiliyor
gönderilen
exception
yakalanamıyor
uncode
exception
terminate
de
abortu
çağırdı
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
ama diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
burada bir
try blue var
ve
iostream
başlık dosyasında
mincode
edelim
şimdi bakınız
bir
bu hata meselesi
yakalanacak mı?
evet
çünkü
out of range
logic error
sınıfından
sınıfı da
exception
sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilmiş
bu şu demek
bu exception'ı
budaya kadar
bunu
yorum
satırına
alacağım
aslında
out of range'in
tavan sınıfı
olan
hiyerarşiyi daha sonradan
anlatacağım
logic error
sınıfı
türünden
catch parametresi
kullanıyorum
bu da
yakalayacak
ve
şimdi de
gerçek sınıfın
kendisi
yani
out of range
sınıfı
türünden
catch parametresi
yakalıyorum
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi soru
önce soruyu anlamaya
sonra cevap vermeye
çalışın
mesela
bunların
hepsi
aynı
try blogunu
izleyen
farklı
catch blogları
olabilir miydi
evet
ama burada
ne yapmanız
gerekiyor
özelden
genele
sıralamanız
gerekiyor
yani örneğin şöyle yazsaydınız
lütfen dikkatli izleyin
zaten
arkadaşlar
gönderilen
out of range de olsa
out of range
yakalamayacak ki
yukarıdan aşağı doğru
bakıldığı için
exception yakalayacak
derleyicilerin
çok büyük çoğunluğu
compile time'da
bu kontrolü
yapıyorlar
yani ben bu konu
derlediğimde
muhtemelen
derleyiciden
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
bir uyarı
mesajı alacağım
ama diyelim ki
uyarı
mesajını
dikkate
almadım
şuraya
yazayım
x
to the exception
diye
buradan
anlayalım
diğerlerinde
yazı yok
arkadaşlar
gönderilen hata nesnesi
out of range
türünden olmasına
rağmen
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
stut
exception
yakaladı
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
gönderilen
hata nesnesinin
buraya dikkat
hatta
şuraya
yazalım
referans
semantiğiyle
yakalanması
2-3
nedenden
çok önemli
yani
bu bir
catch
bloğu olsun
diyelim ki
burada
my
exception
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
catch bloğu
oluşturursanız
ki bazen ben
kodlarda görüyorum
bu eleştiriye
konu
olur
yani
genelde
yanlış olarak
kabul edilir
neden
kaç
nedenden
dolayı
bir
bir kere
söyleyin bakalım
my
exception
türü
polimorfik
bir sınıf
türü ise
burada
ne deniyordu
ona
ne gerçekleşecek
hatırlayan var mı
o terimi
bakın
sınıf türü
ne referans
değil
bir arkadaşım
söylesin
object
slicing
bravo
object slicing
olacak
yani
dinamik türü
zaten
kaybedeceğim
bir kere
bu nedenden
sırf bu nedenden
kabul edilebilir
değil
ama başka
nedeni de var
arkadaşlar böyle yaparsam
burada
bu sınıf için
copy
constructor
çağrılacak
değil mi
a
bunun bir maliyeti
var
yani maliyeti
olabilir
var derken
b
bir de
burada çağrılan
copy
constructor
kendisi de
bir fonksiyon
değil mi
o fonksiyonun da
exception
türü
etme
ihtimali var
yani ben
exception
handle
ederken
yine bir
exception
gönderilirse
bir dahaki
terste
göreceğiz
yine
terminate
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
ilerledik
ancak buraya
kadar gelebildik
asıl konunun
önemli
büyük kısmı
çarşamba
günkü dersimizde
anlatılacak
ben
Necati Ergin
bugünkü derse
katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
çarşamba
günü görüşmek
üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
eriyiz
ㅋㅋㅋ
benim
o
Maryland